to the just pearly things YouTube
channel and welcome to the pregame
back again with another podcast good
evening and hi and welcome to Auntie
Jenny's Village Auntie Jenny's podcast
it's your boy The Fresh Prince of
someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men now I'm
not saying you have to be submissive to
every old waste man walking around I'm
just saying that it would be femininity
would be in your nature breaking it is
to find somebody you're compatible with
that you like not just of your same
generation and that likes the same
things that you do going out having fun
okay okay then then get out then get out
after Esther then get out I'm not here
to get canceled today most men want a
woman that has some degree of femininity
where they feel like they're taking care
of taking care of and Lady night I'm
submissive and you'd be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say what I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm gonna look down on him because
at the end of the day whoever you're
with is a reflection of you what has
happened since you that has made the
normal man a waste man I would feel so
bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag now he's
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started so a couple announcements before
we start the show today the first is um
what what super chats are we reading
over today
King
oh 20 20 bucks okay so we are reading
all super chats over twenty dollars you
know be nice guys
um also guys
um today uh we have two clips channels
just pearly clips and pearl daily we
also have four membership tiers so the
first tier gets you to be a part of the
live chat which here we are opening at
how many likes King
um one thousand all right a thousand
likes and we will open the chat today
um second tier you get to be a part of
our Discord and our behind the scenes
Vlogs third tier you get to connect with
me on social media and the fourth tier
you get a one-on-one call with me once a
month want to know how to get a million
subscribers in a year sign up for the
fourth tier guys um also they took away
my Instagram so if you want to follow me
on Instagram it's just pearly things one
you can also submit
um content or show topics or show
questions on my Instagram also guys um
we do have an interview coming out on
Rumble where I learn more about like
deep State type stuff so if you want to
follow my Rumble go do that also guys
subscribe to wife school I'm going to
the US next month and we plan on filming
a lot of wife School content there
also guys we have three Talent channels
so make sure you go subscribe to King
Richie's Auntie Jenny um and also um The
Fresh Prince of zamun Munda Munda I'm
sorry I try uh but amiri's Channel
amiri's really close to a thousand
subscribers he's at like 850 so if you
guys could get him 150 more subs we
would really appreciate it because that
is what he needs to be monetized on
YouTube
um also guys we have an animation
Channel if you liked the intro um and
you liked the the coffee talk thing they
had in the intro and there's a guy that
does animations for us it's just pearly
animations
um and yeah I think that's all my
announcements today
um so today we have a lovely panel um so
we are gonna go around and everyone say
your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact about yourself
starting here and then go around
okay my name is Gigi I'm 22 and a fun
fact
um I'm a Virgo
that's like as far as it gets happy
my name is music I'm 25 and
um what's a fun fact
um
I have a phobia of mushrooms so I will
run a mile like I have a favorite a
mushroom yes and insects but I feel like
that's normal what relationship status
uh take him take him okay hello my name
is Toriano Lou Tory for short I'm 24. I
am seeing someone and a fun fact
I shake a lot because I take inhaler so
I'm not scared I just shake
[Music]
hi all my name's Bella I'm 24. I am
um taken
and a fun fact about me uh is that was
an X Factor that's kind of fun I guess
if you're on the X Factor yeah man I
thought I thought you might have known
that no did you see you just hit me up
no I don't really do the recruiting
wait what did you do on it I'm singing
I'm singing here oh that's so cool is
that is that what Simon Cowell's on or
is that someone else yeah yeah I was
these Golden Buzzer which was which was
great do you know what do you know what
I love about him he's really small in
person when you meet this guy he's
really really sure he's great he's full
of character but just just compact oh
that's so cool oh go ahead I'm sure I'm
30 and I'm currently single but I just
kind of met someone sent me recently
okay I mean fun fact
and I got like a weird one I got
poisoned by a fish when I was younger
kind of weird how like what kind of fish
was it I don't know I was in the
Philippines I'm Filipinas when I was a
kid
um and I was a rock pool and I just
caught one they've poisoned me oh wow
okay
hi I'm Shay
um
I'm single fun fact about me is I speak
three language so I might pronounce
wrong words but please correct me
absolutely fine uh what was the third
one sorry name age relationship status
and fun fact and I'm 25 okay thank you
hi guys my name is cintish most people
might know me as brown and bougie I am
23 I am also single fun fact about me um
I don't know how to ride a bike
tell them tell them what you didn't do
after last show oh basically I didn't
call back my ex I I said I said column I
thought I would but I feel like that's
just done it's just not meant to be it's
not it's not
I'm I'm pro-love here so I feel like I
feel like I feel like if if I really
wanted to get back with an ex I don't
know you never know maybe one day I'll
call him just for you yeah just for them
we're pro-love here
um okay so today
um oh guys I forgot to announce this in
the beginning I need to put this in my
intro notes um we do have a Google form
um that you can put your email and your
phone number in you can put in one or
the other um if you don't want to put
them both but it'll give you guys
notifications when we do meetups in the
UK and the US um we actually want to
bring in like old show people and like
maybe do a concert of some sort you know
she's our Top Choice now yeah
um but yeah sign up for the Google
um form if you want to be notified when
we do that
um so today um we are going to talk
about a clip that went viral
um do you want to pull up the first clip
um so today's topic is average average
men aren't enough
now something that inspired this topic
was this clip that went viral on Twitter
I'm just curious I'm gonna show it on
the screen have any of you seen this
okay
foreign
oh okay are you gonna oh okay we're
having Tech issues
um okay I guess I'll ask you guys so
we're gonna be talking about
um what type of jobs you guys like to
date
so um if you I'm curious in your last
relationship or your current
relationship what does he do
um so you can start here yeah you go
first
were you taking a single I can't
remember I forgot to say I'm actually
single right now
um the last person I was speaking to
um I think he had like multiple jobs I
think one of them was like in like um
you know those like gym
membership things I think he was in like
a gym and then he also did football on
the side but not like professional and
then I think that was it I think okay so
we worked in a gym yeah
yeah yeah go ahead what did he do
oh um
my current
the current person works as a private
Banker okay and
previously
oh entertainment like artist okay so
like a musician yeah okay
so he's an entrepreneur but he runs a
removal company but it's not like low
level it's okay it's high level it's
worked hard at it yeah he does really
well okay okay
um he's a rapper yeah he's a really good
rapper actually amazing
um what what is your the personal plan I
just met no she's a dance teacher and
the model as well okay but you know just
to add out there like do you know what I
wouldn't what I realized later in life
what I don't want is I don't want to
have a boss woman I'd rather just have
like my woman which I mean not big
didn't know that stuff
what made you what made you decide that
have you dated a boss woman before yeah
do you know what I just
I just came to realization that I like I
believe more in the traditional
um relationship
and you know speaking to my own mom my
own family and they think the same thing
and I think it's the best way to
progress for me personally have you ever
dated a girl that made more than you
uh yeah when I was younger when you were
younger yeah do you feel like she still
was able to respect you in the
relationship yeah definitely she wasn't
even when I was on the way up as well
like when I was younger I was trying to
pursue a career in uh basketball okay
and she had like a good job in um she
was like a lecturer and stuff so that
[__] lent me a car to get to go to
trials and like even him out for food
and stuff she would like boss me a card
in that and um it does it makes me feel
like they masculated in that so now I'm
in a position where that's not the case
and yeah I wouldn't want to go back it
made you feel demasculated we get paid
for things most definitely when I was
young it doesn't happen like once
sideway but you should pass me the card
but
okay yeah
um what what did your either no you said
you were single so your last boyfriend
um I've dated but I've never like had a
boyfriend
um okay the last guy you were really
into yeah
um
like for me it's it's more about if you
make the same income of me with of me or
higher so it's not really about the job
for me you can do anything if you're
passionate about if you love it I don't
mind but is are you are we making are
you right so what what did he do
uh I haven't actually asked when I go on
days I have an artist it's like I go on
days I get to know you so how would you
know if he makes the same or more
you you know by like the way you act and
um where we go and I think for me before
jobs I think I want to put that date on
your credit card
but okay um I would say like business
just normal business so um it's an
international business okay so like
sales maybe type stuff yeah okay that's
what it is in the Canary Wharf guys
yeah yeah like a business center but
I was just there today it was like a lot
of Suits
um okay um what did your last boyfriend
do oh the last guy I was dating banged
fraud
[Laughter]
how did a criminal get in the like you
seem like a level-headed woman like how
did a criminal get in the door with you
like I'd imagine back you know if I hear
a crime I'm like ah I don't I don't like
the Crim you know no crime for me back
in the day like I just wasn't the person
I am today like I was very like immature
and just not as level-headed as I used
to be I used to be very much like her
just out there girl so that was the type
of people I was attracting so that's
that's the best way to describe it I was
attracting what I was but I've never
banged food in my life
I'll keep my credit cards
I was the video already okay so have you
guys seen this video I have I've seen it
you know I've seen it found it really
funny okay don't you know but I'm gonna
interview but you you about it last but
everyone else okay God
it is MD phds we also are the fastest
growing group of entrepreneurs along
with latino women in America Pew
research said that women are now out
earning men out earning me and 22 of the
largest cities in America including
where I live New York dcla you name it
when we talk and I know that you've said
that you cannot teach a man or tell a
man how to be a man so I will not ask
you to indict men in this question but I
do want you to speak ayanda to
how women need to
uh I don't know position ourselves so
that we can be in our Divinity so we can
have our crowns right how we can create
and not build when some of us quite
frankly feel that the men that are
available to us and I'm talking about
across the color spectrum across the age
Spectrum trust me I've done them all
um they are not positioned to protect
nor provide because of some of the
statistics we just talked about they're
not earning the incomes they're not
having the resources and some of them
are not even showing up in the
leadership
would you date a bus driver
you would you date if he owns the bus if
he owns the bus that's the problem
that's a problem because the standards
and requisites and I'm not talking about
him laying on his sofa playing video
games all day I'm not talking about that
but the standards and the criteria that
we use to measure men is off for who we
are as women and who they are in this
Society I would date a bus driver if he
was if he loved driving the bus if he
was a man of integrity if he was good to
his mama if he treated me well I would
date a bus driver but we think that it's
another human being's responsibility to
give us what we need instead of us
building together I can build with a bus
driver I'd have my little stash over on
the side in my prenup but I could build
with a bus truck so I think some of the
criteria that we look for in the reality
of today Keeps Us unhappy Keeps Us angry
Keeps Us imbalance and then when the men
show up we want to beat them up because
they're not living up to our standards
and criteria and and it's not working
beloved it's just not working so it's
not that it's bad or wrong it's obsolete
it's obsolete we have to come up with a
new way of being I don't believe in
carrying a man a man has to do for
himself my son got his first job when he
was nine
nine okay because you're a black man you
will know how to take care of yourself
but I think the way we measure it
it's it's just obsolete
I think that's a factual analysis if you
can whatever we want expect Okay so
my first question would you date a bus
driver
no no
if you own the bus
well she said no I'm joking um
that's it's just so surface level to ask
that though isn't it no there's bus
drivers that are trying to take women on
like like you guys on dates and they
want to know if you would you know you
would date them how much do bus drivers
earn um
[Music]
us
there's probably like levels though
isn't there like I mean I'm just gonna
look it up bus drivers sorry London
15 pounds an hour so like I mean that's
like 18 US Dollars 15 pounds an hour
foreign
I'm gonna say no now but
come back to me okay so no no I think I
very much agree with with what she said
like if you're passionate in what you do
a lot of people earn way less than 15
pounds an hour
you're you're grafting and at the end of
the day you might be able to change that
later on down the line so yeah if I get
along with you well you're presenting
yourself or you're treating me well 100
yeah yeah no I would but I I used to
before I went out with with my my now
partner who's a man I went out with two
females and if if I said that
um obviously when it was when I was with
a woman obviously you know like we was
50 50 in and things like that so if I
would do that with a woman then kind of
sort of not I'm saying like I don't like
being treated by a man but for me
personally and someone who's been out
with both females and males how can I
hold a man to a higher standard of
having to look after me when my previous
partner who was a female didn't have to
earn as much it would be for me
personally stupid to say well yeah my
man's got an x amount because I never
asked that as my female partner so what
I'd have to ask out of my male partner
are your standards exactly the same when
you look at men and women yeah I think
so I think so I think so I never saw
myself with a man and so
um so I think it took me by surprise so
I think it's it's it's not you never so
you were always like a lesbian before
and then you found this guy and he was
an exception yeah yeah I don't think it
was an exception because now I like
obviously apart from I'm so sorry baby
you are the only man I find attractive
but like that obviously I'm like it's I
wouldn't rule out ever like be just be
like he's the only man ever you know
what I mean if that makes sense
um but um yeah but I can't hold one in a
certain respect without holding the
other in the same respect so if I said
to my female partner like you know yeah
it's fine for you to earn the same as me
and put 50 50 in then how can I not be
like that with my man but that's just
that's just I think a personal thing of
going through that experience you know
it's interesting because I've had other
girls that were bi on the show and they
actually said they had like higher
standards for the guys than they do for
the women I just I'm just realistic like
I'm just logical like I think it's just
logic that you know if you're gonna go
out with both then you can't have
different stands to scan you because at
the end of the day you're asked him for
the same thing which is love in the same
capacity that I would ask love from a
woman is the same capacity that I would
ask a lot from a man so how can I ask
for different materialistic things if
what I'm asking for is the same is the
relationship Dynamic the same when you
go for men and women
for me personally like the the females I
went out with were kind of tomboyish so
um I'd say that the Dynamics were more
similar than I expected
um I I've always just been attracted to
kind of like the leader of the group
whoever that is whatever color ethnicity
religion uh sex you know what I mean
I've always just been attracted to
someone but not a leader as it makes the
most money more as in character you know
that the kind of brightest the brightest
star in the room the the brightest
character so for me that's that's the
most important thing rather than job
okay uh would you date a bus driver yeah
is there any profession you wouldn't
date
um like I don't stop saying they're like
of stuff no no or any of that type of
stuff and anything that's like
when they have to dress promiscuously or
anything like this okay so now like uh
do you guys have Hooters here no okay
Hooters is like a booty shorts chain in
the U.S where it's like it's like a way
like they're waitresses but they dress
they wear like the orange stuff yeah
yeah yeah bring it to me okay
degeneracy
um okay
um do you so outside of um just like
promiscuous is there any other industry
you wouldn't date
um
do you know what like you know someone
like worked in a zoo as well because I
don't know I don't like the food like
some animals in captivity against their
will and stuff I think that's a bit mad
okay and if they were like Pro that I'll
be like okay morally it might sit a bit
bad Ah that's like a very random I don't
really think about answering the
question yeah um okay uh what about you
would you date a bus driver I would as
she said if he's passionate and he's a
family man and he respects his mom
absolutely I it's fine because I think
the goal is to find a respectful man
that can treat you well
um other than a job we could fix that
later on it's fine if you haven't no no
no no no fixing it it's like he's a bus
drivers that's fine that's fine are you
does that switch your answer
bus driver the rest of his life no it
doesn't no no you slow date him yeah
let's go date him okay uh what about you
um if he had plans to leave the bus
driver job then I would date him um but
if he's planning to stay there for the
rest of his life unfortunately I
couldn't date him because I feel like 15
pounds an hour for the rest of your life
isn't really good plus the long hours
and um I'm gonna be completely honest
with you like ask me if I would date a
bus drivers like ask him a man would you
date Like a Porn Star like in society
ways it's a little bit like you know I
wouldn't say that's the equivalent of a
porn I mean obviously like is a more
like we need bus drivers yes it's
actually a very needed role yeah yeah
but like to to a queen a bus driver to
the like to bottom like 10 of females
yeah but we need porn as well men need
porn so that's how I said you might have
survived for most of History without
corn
yeah for me personally I'm not gonna sit
here and lie and be like oh my gosh I
would personally I just feel like if he
had plans to leave it then yeah because
it's just like 15 pounds an hour for the
rest of your life isn't really it I'm
not gonna lie
um would you rather date a
musician or a bus driver
well my boyfriend's a rapper so I'm
saying musician how successful is the
musician there
um they're both average bus driver
average musician so however successful I
could look up the average musician I
feel like a musician would be more fun I
feel like bus drivers like I might get
in the music video I might have like I
say but if a bus drivers that you're
just taking the same route all the time
I can't really come with you evolve
um but if it's an average musician then
yeah if it's like a big musician and I
don't really know because they're a bit
here and there you know
what about you
I'm guessed we're talking about people
at the start of their music career that
are like you know the guys are like yeah
I wouldn't be I'm an aspiring rapper and
they're like starting out and it's like
they're gonna stay that way it could be
a country singer I don't know okay but
but they're gonna stay at average right
that's the question forever
I think I'm in this case I think
actually rather the bus driver because
at least nobody's seeing him all the
time all over the place
yeah probably yeah I think I'm gonna say
bus driver because I understand the
industry and I'm just yeah I'm way too
jealous of a person to even get with
someone who
who does music is around women all the
time Etc is a lot to take on so yeah bus
driver
I'm gonna have to say musician otherwise
I'm gonna get some really bad texts
after this show
I say um a musician you know if it's
like an average musician that's like
like not saying that people do wedding
ones are like I'm average but Germany
gives you more freedom because I want to
just do my stuff and go on holidays and
it's a bus driver they've got to ask
about how are you going to fund the
holidays if me can't oh yeah you yeah
I'm sorry I'm forgetting that you're a
guy answering it
um depending are they making the same by
the way their average musician and the
average bus driver is it the same salary
average salary of a
musician let's see London
I got you
yeah I just saw that with musicians you
don't even make money in the beginning
yeah that's the thing yeah I feel like
this is a bit off but if it's like kind
of the same salary then I think this one
says 29 000. that sounds more right yeah
I think if it's the same salary I
wouldn't mind I think with a musician I
would have more quality time than the
bus driver
um but I don't mind a bus driver either
just at least with the musician I think
I would have more quality time
in this case I will actually date the
bus driver only because I like peace and
I feel like musicians let's be real we
know what they're about they're out with
girl you know they're cheating all the
time
um the more money a man makes the more
likely he is to cheat and me I I I'm too
emotional for all of that like I like my
mental
um Health To Be steady so yeah it would
have to be the bus driver but I still
wouldn't do it
okay do you guys think you are above
average
and why do you think you deserve an
above average man if so
above average in like what sense like
um the things that men want
um
oh my God
I don't know honestly like I couldn't
really say I don't think I'm like
average I don't think I'm above I think
I'm like in between but like I don't
really so you think you're average or
you don't think you're average
no I don't think I'm average but I feel
like I've seen above average I don't
really know if I am above average though
because it just depends on different
stuff okay but like I don't try to go
for a guy that's like above average
realistically
um for me like I'm not too picky when it
comes to
um materialistic things and stuff like
that and your job title and this this is
but what I've like learned from like
going for guys who have like average
jobs and stuff like that which is like
the only thing I've been used to is that
like I would rather just now like I'd
rather have fun with it than go for a
musician if he's gonna cheat he's gonna
cheat because imagine getting cheated on
by a guy who drives the free for you too
like you drive a race pass that's the
issue that I have with men is that it
doesn't actually matter their title like
if they want to play you they'll play
you so like I said I don't usually go
for above average guys but I might try I
don't know but it's still this person
for me I feel like it's still the same
end game okay but my question is do you
think you're above average so you said
yeah yes I think I think I'm like in
between but I'm just gonna say yeah I'm
just gonna rate myself okay that's fine
there's nothing wrong with saying that
so you think you're above average so and
why do you think um like what do you
bring to the table to an above average
guy
what do I bring to an above average guy
yeah like I'm asking like what because
um I'm a sweetheart like I just feel
like I'm quite nice I can drive I'm fun
you know like that's why I said I don't
really know in what sense you mean above
average because it could be like above
average like financially or like
ambitiously or like physically and stuff
no I don't care about it like that's the
thing yeah mostly I feel like men mostly
care about looks wise and looks wise I'm
never going to sit and say that I'm not
above average because I rate it myself
but in terms of what I think there's
other things that men look for that's
the thing but in terms of what I what
makes me above average for an above
average guy I couldn't really answer
that yet just because I haven't actually
experienced an above average guy if that
makes sense
how tall was your ex-boyfriend
I'm six foot one I think okay so that's
top 15 probably 10 percent of men yeah
so that's above average how much did he
make roughly I don't know I never asked
you don't have any guess I actually do
it there were you the one that said
Banker he was a banker no that was it
wasn't even what did you say he did
football and um some oh the gym the gym
yeah okay so so I I genuine you couldn't
tell you how much she was making
sometimes I didn't know but at least in
luck she was probably above average if
he works at a gym and he's six one
yeah so okay if we're talking about
index yeah yeah so I don't think you're
going for average man but I thought you
meant above average like you know
where's the suit drives a Maserati to
work like that's what I think when I
think above my average I feel like the
guy that I was talking to is my Norm I
feel like he's very much On My Level
because you're high and stuff like that
you just happen to be taller than me but
like if you own a business or if you
have like all of these things for me
personally that's like above my average
yeah I mean there's a couple things that
girls look for so it's like you know
there's looks which height goes into and
then there's money
um status so I would say most girls the
guys they go for are above average in
some way but I feel like um because you
know only like 20 of men are sexually
active
[Music]
but but essentially like 20 of men are
sleeping with like 80 of women
because the number one way the number
one way people are meeting nowadays is
dating apps and that's fine and women
only swipe right five percent of the
time that's crazy yeah and like women
find 80 of that is unattractive like not
not okay not they think they're ugly
so I mean I guess it's not to say that
like the other ones don't ever get in
the door but for the most part women go
for 20 of men oh that's interesting I
didn't know that yeah they did the
studies in person because I know a lot
of people will say oh we don't find 80
of men is ugly but yeah they did the
studies like in person and on dating
apps and like literally 80 of men ugly I
wonder what why that is though is it
purely based on look so stats because
it's swiping so it's purely based on
looks right because I feel like women
looks when it comes to men women don't
really care that much about us as long
as you're well put together well more
you should be concerned with height
height is like I'm not concerned about
her usually
men don't look as good in pictures as
well
you can't really go just off no but it's
not just going after that it's in person
too like they raided the men in person
and they also thought they were ugly
maybe because women's are way more
beautiful features there's way more like
different attributes well women wear
makeup so we've got and like we got we
got things
yeah but he could do it he could do a
top of this photo yeah I think women
just have higher standards like they
actually say that women um judge like
men heart more harsh on appearance than
men judge women
so even if let's just say we tripled it
like in person she finds three times as
many people attractive it's still only
15 I think that's contributing to why
women are just single in the yeah on
their rates are going up for why women
are not really married and single by 25
and 30 because
yeah the standards are definitely gone
High
um so uh the same question though like
what would you say you bring outside of
looks
like
um
outside of looks
um okay obviously like personality
um and just more rules as well and like
ambition worth epic I feel like I'm not
really the type to just kind of sit down
and just be bummy like I'm always trying
to like better myself and work harder
and stuff like that which I personally
feel like is a good thing because I want
that inner guy too I feel like that's a
very attractive thing to like be
ambitious and then other than that um I
can keep I can cook a few bits and Bobs
nothing too crazy
um like I said like I can actually drive
so I'm not gonna be like oh my guy needs
to have a car and I can't drive that she
can actually have a car
um and then I'm very like family
oriented I have good morals like like I
said I feel like personally no I feel
like it looks as it can only get you so
far I feel like like your soul like
internally you have like you have to
check those boxes too so I feel like I
took those boxes as well
okay uh what about you um do you think
you're above average and what do you
bring to an above average man
yes I do think I'm above average uh what
do I bring to the table
um
I just feel like Leah looks is like one
thing it's the surface right but I take
pride in my appearance so it's not just
like makeup and all of like oh getting
Botox or lip fillers and stuff it's not
that I'm talking about facials manicures
pedicures like health and well-being
going to the gym like going to the
doctors like these type of things like
beyond the surface like I actually
really take care of myself like
moisturizing like I know it sounds like
oh I just creamed my skin but like I
take really good pride in that like my
skin is really soft so I'm happy about
that
um that's just on the surface but then
like in terms of other things like as a
woman I just feel like I'm very
nurturing maybe it's my stuff to do my
star sign if you guys believe in that
stuff or it's just me my just biological
makeup but I'm very nurturing um in
terms of like my duties in the household
like cleaning and cooking I will always
do for for whatever man that I'm with
because it just comes naturally to me
um in times I was like I do like 100 of
the household chores yeah yeah yeah well
as in usually like well the person I'm
with now he does Parts as well because
he likes to be clean as well so that's a
good thing but I'll I'm happy to do like
90 of it I've got this Theory like I
want tradition to play like 85 90 in the
relationship but that that 15 10 is just
modern day Society we're not in the
1950s anymore things have changed so
that 15 10 means that the man can do the
dishwasher sometimes or the woman can
like go and work sometimes as well like
it's okay but I feel like our roles
should
um overpower the other percentage if you
get what I'm trying to say
um but yeah like I I definitely feel
like I bring a lot to the table not that
my man or anyone I should ask me what I
bring to the table because I think he
should just
I don't like that question from a man
but I don't know what I asked yeah yeah
you're a woman yeah because I'm going to
tell you how but like as a man I
wouldn't that would be a completely red
flag if he's like demanding what seeking
yeah like because I just don't yeah I
think men should ask women what they
bring I think my women should ask men
too you might want to phrase you might
not phrase it like that I've never asked
a man what you bring to what you mean
you might not phrase it like that but
you want to know what his job is you
want to know what his relationship with
his family like they ask it to you they
just don't do it that directly typically
like guys will ask you questions on
dates to like figure out stuff about you
but do you think that's because men we
can ask men because what we're asking
for is more to see like if they provide
and stuff and that's more like factual
like what I do for a job what I earn
whereas a woman it's more you need to
experience her to see if she you can't
you can say I'm nurturing but you might
not be you need to kind of be around her
see how she is how to see how she talks
but yeah adding to life you can ask like
um when's the last time you like babysat
or watch children
like how often do you interact with kids
that's the way you could tell
um
yeah is that a good indication yeah I
think so if you want a mother like you
don't think like doing the thing that
you would have to do if you're a mom
because nurturing guys Beyond kids but
yeah okay it's I'm just saying that's
one way yeah yeah but there's like ways
you can ask the question yeah yeah yeah
fair enough that's fair that's fair but
I think men should ask more questions to
be honest
because I I think that like a lot of
guys don't ask the right questions and
they get bamboozled later I know but I
like the level of like mystery that a
woman carries and I think that's her
femininity like you shouldn't I don't
think you should tell a man a lot
especially well if he's your partner of
course but when you're first dating him
I don't think you should tell him a lot
because you could tell him the facts of
course but don't air out your dirty
laundry and stuff because you're a woman
you're feminine you that mystery that
Mystique isn't really important I think
yeah but you know okay there's a
difference between airing like talking
about your ex-boyfriend and answering
questions he asks you know like yeah as
long as the questions are appropriate no
I think like when guys ask you questions
and you don't answer it's like not
feminine yeah because I think it's like
disappears on the question I guess I
think it's like disagreeable yeah if
you're gonna okay let's let's say like
this if a guy said to me what's your
body count I'm not gonna answer him
because I just think that's
inappropriate disrespectful Actually I
don't even want to talk to you anymore
so I'm just going to get up
I think men should know that to be
honest um I don't think I think it's
disrespectful if it's someone like you
don't know I mean I disrespect like it's
it's private right but it's like if he
wants to if he's taking you seriously
and wants to marry you I think it's a
valid question I just think it's only
valid if you've been with someone that
he is associated with like friends or
family I feel like a guy that has no
kind of connection to your guy I don't
think it actually matters and
furthermore you can ask a woman however
many times what her body count is first
of all she's always gonna lie and even
if she doesn't lie how do you know she's
telling the truth were you in her body
for all the years she's been alive women
tell on themselves like I start to count
because you'll be like okay that's what
guys tell me that the women will tell on
themselves later yeah I think most guys
like don't ask to be fair but I mean
when you look at the numbers as a guy I
don't know how you wouldn't care
especially men have so much to lose in
divorce um court today it's like if the
girl's a virgin on her wedding wedding
night she has an 80 chance of a happy
marriage you know it drops down to if
she slept with more than five people
twenty percent so if you've slept with
more than five people your chance of a
happy marriage in 10 years goes down to
20 percent
and if you slept with more than 10 it's
like you're you're probably going to be
divorced like more likely than not
within five years have they said what
the reason is for that I mean I think
it's good I think it's going against
nature like throughout all of history
like when have women been as promiscuous
as they are today you don't undo biology
just because we have birth control now
so do you think that's down to because
she's experienced so many partners that
she then doesn't feel fulfilled or do
you think it's down to the man finding
out and not respect to know what do you
think what's the women leaving so it's
not the man like women usually leave not
men
um so it
I think it's the psychology of choice if
you have 10 meals in front of you and
you pick one you're not as happy but if
there's one in front of you you're ha
you're just happy to be eaten You Know
What I Mean
Girls start to compare so they'll say
like the first guy he had this second
yeah you're not no it's true no I agree
with that she'd agree with that yeah
yeah and then I think like the the more
you've been with it's like the odds are
the guy you married isn't your favorite
and so now you're getting married to
your second choice is that good
and I think we can all like think of a
girl that maybe had an ex that she kept
going back to or didn't get over maybe
an actually you that happened to you you
know
um I think that's common because women
start running out of time so they run to
their like second or third choice
um true that's what I think anyway you
know that never happens to any of us but
yeah no I mean I mean the data honestly
shows that half of us aren't going to
have kids
50 in here single and childless if you
hit 30 and you're still single you're so
if you're if you had 30 you're still
single your chance of having a kid drops
below 50 so you're actually more likely
to not have a kid than have one is that
just females yeah yeah women I rebuke
these stats and I um no no it's not like
rebuking I think I think it's good for
women to know because that's what's
gonna happen if like you know and it's a
fact as well like your eggs just help
them yeah yeah yeah yeah we know that
yeah but ninety percent of your eggs are
gone by 30 and then they sell you IVF as
an option but the majority of IVF
treatments don't work so the majority of
women that go get like IVF they don't
actually get get a kid at all
I'm just a firm believer I feel like the
way my my life is supposed to pan out it
will pan out just perfectly and yeah the
stacks are important but I just feel
like if I'm not ready now and I'm ready
later and it doesn't happen
maybe it just wasn't meant to be I'll
just leave it to life
yeah I think a lot of women feel like
that but you know then they hit 45 and
they're on antidepressants and more
depressed than any other group like
women over the age of 45 or more
depressed than any other group like more
anxious and the same thing like body
count is associated to all those things
like anxiety depression like I can't
remember the list off the top of my head
but there's a bunch of like negative
like things that are associated like
negative mental health with high body
count and sometimes you don't really
know when you're ready until what
happens so we're not with like my
brother has a baby and he was he thought
he wasn't ready to be a dad until baby
happened and he's a great father yeah
you become ready right yeah yeah
sometimes you need the moment to
to understand what you can and can't do
if that makes sense
the women that are depressed
um do they have children no no yeah
that's sorry I might not have said
childless single childless
um
um do you think you're above average and
what would you bring to an above average
man I would say I'm currently average
because I have a lot of improvement that
needs to happen
um
my mind is above average
and what I bring to
the table as a sense is um
same thing you said babe I am very
nurturing the job that I have allows me
to
you know I feel like I'm going to be a
very good mum I feel like I'm very
caring
um
money-wise I'm able to take care of
certain things as well so the pressure
isn't all on him I know a lot of people
think oh you know it should be because
he's the man absolutely I agree with
that but I want to help I don't want to
feel useless
household even if I'm just providing
groceries do you know what I mean a
little bit of something
um very understanding I I listen to a
lot of things my ears are open
yeah I think that is it's important um
I don't go clubbing a lot there's you
know I haven't been with a lot of people
before him there's a lot of things that
that would make me uh worthy perhaps of
being with someone like that if you're
attracted in a above average man
wouldn't you say you like your above
average because you kind of are what you
attract so he's he's older than me
um and at the moment
I think as humans we'd be silly to think
that we don't have a lot of growth
there's always room for improvement I'm
not going to sit here and be like oh
yeah I'm above average no babe I've got
[__] to I've got [__] to work on do you
know what I mean it isn't a negative
thing no no no and honestly it shows
humility that you're like saying that to
be honest which I think is something men
look for
yeah perhaps
um but yeah even for myself I know that
I've got a lot of growth that's good I
need to happen so yeah what are you
looking to improve on
um
work wise I can make a lot more money I
can improve in that area my my body can
be a lot better my hair could be a
little longer do you know men men don't
care about money uh yeah exactly
um some do
but the bombs yeah
but it's just nice if the person that
you're with has got ambition at least
that's you know what I mean
um no with with the person that I'm with
he doesn't really care about money but
because what are you where are you going
in life yeah otherwise I can get of any
woman what are you bringing What Makes
You Different so I've got ambition you
know what is that I do in life that's
what intrigues him
okay what else
um what do you mean are you looking to
improve on so you said money
um yeah it's okay if it's just that I
was just curious uh yeah money Fitness
uh mental health as well I think that's
very important
um I've still got a lot of a lot of
growth to do in that area I think we
were doing many 24 so I have a lot more
work to do but um
yeah I think oh and also being more more
calm listening to him because I've also
been very dominant in the past he's told
me that so I'm trying to be a bit more
submissive yeah a bit more feminine
that's it
where do you like why do you think
you've been more dominant in the past
like where does that come from is that
something you saw modeled growing up or
is that just a trade about you so I
didn't really have a dad grown up so
therefore I've naturally had to been had
to be a bit more masculine I've had to
fend for myself I also grew up in a bit
of a hood area you could say so yeah I
came from a bit of a rough background in
a sense but um I feel like I'm dragging
myself out of it and bettering myself
how do you because I've always wondered
how if you didn't grow up in that
environment how do you learn to be like
a wife or more feminine like where do
you go
um
he has taught me a lot
um what I've what I've seen a lot of my
family members and friends have also
taught me and if you're not willing to
learn and change you never go into you
have to be able to do that yourself it
doesn't matter what background you've
come from you have to be willing to
learn and to change and then you're
going to it's that simple
and what about you
um I think
I don't say I am above average then who
else is gonna say it do you know what I
mean if I don't back myself first then I
don't think I'll ever become above
average
um I think you know your mind is the
most powerful thing and you kind of are
what you think kind of the same as you
are what you eat type Vibes so if I
don't think I'm above average and not
what I bring to the table that I I I'm I
am the [__] table I'm the table you
know what I mean and I might not be your
table but he might like the oak table
with a wonky leg and you know and and
and a crochet doily on top right and and
here over there might want a marble
table but I will be somebody's table
so what are you what's on the table
what's on the team
okay what's on the table
um well um I think I can have a laugh
I'm funny
um again I'm very nurturing I'm a big
heart
um I've I've been through a lot um
so I I tend to have you know um a lot in
common with you know I usually find
more so like men that I've been around
or or or now my my now partner has been
through a lot and I think as a female
I've gone through quite a lot
um that you know not always some females
have have been through just because you
know I've been around a lot of boys and
where I was gay I was always hanging out
with boys so now when I when I sit with
my man now is that we've got quite a lot
in common which is great
um I I can cook sort of like he's
probably laughing at me right now
how often do you cook for how often do I
cook for him it depends because we don't
live together so this week how many
times have you cooked oh I've cooked
like twice three times I love cooking
breakfast he always gets breakfast easy
he always gets breakfast of me but um
you know it's a learning curve I just um
you know and and you know if you don't
like the I'm not cooking another frame
I'm sorry
that's kind of like the vibrant I like
I'm not coming with what I'm bringing to
the table is that I am the table in
whatever shape or form and and you know
and and the table might get a liquor
paint and and it might get a new legs or
something like that and but I understand
but it's not what's on the table I am
what's holding everything up can I ask
you a question you mentioned how like um
you know the mind is powerful and what
you think of yourself but do you also
feel like there's a point where you can
also be realistic about where you are
presently yeah no for sure I think
I've learned to be very determined
because I've lost five Stone which was a
mass which was a massive thing so for a
long time I didn't think I bought
anything to the table let alone be in
the table let alone thinking I was above
average I spent a lot of my a lot of my
youth thinking I was well below average
especially being a a when you're
overweight when I was overweight
struggling with with well you are below
average if you're overweight yeah so
yeah yeah yes yeah no no it's true yeah
yeah I mean I'm sure you can see the
level of attention you get now from when
you're overweight a million percent a
million percent so yeah this is I was a
fat kid too yeah
so I like it so I I really have like
when I show people pictures of what I
used to look like wow
so I gen like that I've had to back
myself I've had to say it I like that I
am the table I bring everything to the
table and and I think that's what makes
me essentially do it because I'm I'm
saying I kind of embody that that I
think it but it's just like I almost
think of this as like a job right
because I I personally I think like
being a wife is like applying for a job
if you want to be married I know not
everyone does but it's like when you
come to the a job interview and you just
say well I am the job
come on try that next time
like what do you do like what if you're
in this job like what
what for me I'm kind I'm kind that that
for me uh is what I bring today I'm a
kind person and and if you don't like
that then there's the door but that is
essentially the bare minimum that I
bring to the table is is that I'm a I'm
I think I'm a kind soul and I love
Philly with my whole heart and I think
that that's the biggest thing that me
personally I can bring to the table
interesting nobody said like I want to
have kids
the first I wanted to get to but yeah I
can cook for a family of this many like
you know it's I don't even have kids I
do want to have kids
um okay or would you if you found a guy
tomorrow that you really like could you
have kids like you're ready to go me
yeah but I got a boyfriend okay so would
you if he said tomorrow I'm ready to get
married and have kids yeah like right
now so let's start I mean I would try
and negotiate and try and get him to
extend this but I mean if he's like dead
on it
because no guy's gonna want to like
force you to have his child you know
what yeah but it's like what you said I
feel like because every other box is
ticked I feel secure I feel like you'll
be a good dad
um you're in a good position we can
financially handle it like what it's
fine I just feel like it's the only part
is the selfish aspect of me not wanting
to have kids is because I feel like I
just want to live my life that's the
whole element 25. would you want to have
children I
I'm gonna rethink it around 28. do you
feel like you're not ready to have
children yet
I don't feel ready no but like you said
I probably am if if it happened sorry
are you more of like a career person
that's your focus I am quite career
driven yes what do you think like will
make you happier in the future your
career or like having children
I think having kids and a family and a
husband 100 over the career 100 and I
want to be a housewife for a period of
my life as well yeah so I'm curious so
I'm curious like why why not go for that
first then
because women in my industry the time is
ticking right what's your industry media
and presenting so I can't I don't know I
got a lady that was 55 like 50 000 Subs
in three months oh yeah Auntie yeah yeah
yeah no it's true and maybe it's Society
pushing its own standards on me maybe
and it's scaring me yeah
being young and beautiful there is an
advantage yeah I'm not I'm not going to
deny that yeah it's not like you can't
have a media it's true it's true but I
feel like I still got a bit of time to
play with currently for the kids thing
we're running out of time with the kids
we are how many how many kids do you
want
about maybe just one oh
yeah maybe one or two one or two two two
two two two
okay yeah I guess I guess not too many
not too many yeah just don't don't play
with fire it's true it's true do
fertility tests work and stuff like do
they really show you how yeah I think so
well isn't that something we can
actively practice then what fertility
yeah to see how fertile we are yeah I
just I just know yeah yeah I know
because I want to do one another girls
that got to like 28 and then they like
they couldn't have kids
so this is why I'm going to do it like I
said yeah have you been on birth control
at all no I'm okay no that's good yeah
that's one of the reasons why I came off
birth control because of the fertility
okay
have you ever been on birth control you
said no no no no no it's in I haven't
been on it for a very long time so
that's one of the reasons that is in
ages so yeah okay
um do you feel like you're above average
and what do you Brewing to an above
average woman
super arrogant to say but you know for
like the to the average male in 2023
it's not hard to be above average like
if you break it to categories like
physically spiritually career-wise
friendship relationship with family I
feel like physically
um I train every day so in that sense
I feel like I'm above average
um
you said the statistic earlier about
being over six foot luckily I'm six one
so that's another thing above average
okay um in terms of career like I've had
a mad career I've achieved a lot I've
got a degree for my mum in case anything
else failed
um I've achieved all my goals I set out
in the modeling World um oh you're a
model yeah so I've achieved I took me
like six years to achieve all of them
goals what did you do for the for the
goals the modeling so like for example
like when I was 24 I used to stand in
that Birmingham city center and look at
a billboard and before I ever did a
photo shoot my whole life and said one
day I'm going to be on there then it'd
be like International bookings then
it'll be stores in London then it'll be
certain brands I'd want to shoot for
this and that and then yeah I did them
all and they were all very like clearly
written out next to my bed I took them
all off as I go along yeah and then um
showed so much gratitude along the way
as well so it's just like because you
know when you come from nothing like
when you have something it's like it's
like the best feeling ever so yeah in
that sense of what I could do in terms
of like spiritually I've been on my
spiritual journey found peace Within
Myself I've revisit old stuff
um my communications A1 in relationships
things like this so I think I bring a
lot and the question you asked earlier
about when I'm like when I speak to a
female I ask them questions and I say
like what do you bring to the table
because I'm bringing XYZ
um but yeah now now I'm like I've kind
of like um
bulletproof my philosophies in in
regards to what I want in a relationship
so I very much know if this person is
going to be the one for me I feel like
that's the station right now you know
it's funny like everything you said was
like results oriented so you said you're
above average in looks and you but if
you model your top 20 looks roughly
because you wouldn't get a modeling
contract if you weren't yeah so I mean
that's that's like um is it subjective
and it's what Society dictates as well
what's like
no no like if you look at dating app
data people tend to find the same types
of people attractive but there's some
people that would like hate tattoos or
some people don't hate I mean there's
like a little bit of subjectivity to it
but not really like a lot now okay yeah
but yeah in that sense and then when you
say like um I had this in my career like
you listed the accomplishment yeah yeah
it was just interesting because when men
answer they usually answer more like
results where it's like girls it's more
like feelings yeah yeah I feel that
do you think you're above average and
what do you bring to an above average
guy I think I am an average girl and she
said Tory it's a bit silly if we if we
don't grow there's always time to grow
there's always space for knowledge
um I grew up in a very religious
household so for me it is quite
naturally to submit once you understand
how things go it's not a bad thing like
it's not negative it's not toxic if
anything I feel like in this Society
this this modern world do you know how
powerful you are as a woman to submit in
this world you can be an animal if you
want to you have the freedom to say I'm
a I'm a slug and yet you choose to
submit for your man I find that very
powerful and there's nothing wrong with
that I feel like it makes sense there is
balance in the house he knows what to do
you know what to do and it just brings
nurture as well and you taught me that
as well oh thank you but I did grow up
in a in some kind of house okay so you
have a model of like a that's that's
that's something guys look for in your
family background for sure with my
family I'm not allowed to move out until
I get married really yeah I there's a
line that I can't I've heard I've heard
guys say that's like a green flag where
it's like yeah if she still lives with
her parents that's good I've heard guys
say if she like they look at your family
background to see if your mom's submit a
dear Dad yeah I'm actually 25. if it
gets like late I'll have a phone call
like where are you what time are you
coming home yes I live with my family
too when I was younger I didn't like it
at all but now that I'm 25 I appreciate
it so much because I've avoided so much
I've avoided so much it's amazing yeah
so thank you my brother thank you Mom
thank you everyone honestly
um okay I do have anything else you want
to add to it do you live at home you
know you've seen a successful
relationship uh what else
um you know to cook I I I've I got
forced to learn how to cook I could
almost learn how to kind of hated it but
now I'm so thankful honestly what types
of food do you like to cook so I love
Arab food so for me it's all about the
rice and the chicken and the sauce
so I would say that yeah
but I don't mind learning other other
culture as well I don't really mind
could you date a man outside your
culture
um if you've got fearing yes for me you
need God in your life otherwise there is
there is just I don't think anything can
be successful but that's my opinion
because if you don't and and a family
family man because swim if you don't
respect your mom you're not going to
respect a stranger I ever went to what
religion are you so I grew up uh dad was
Christian mum was Miss Slim So I did
have both sides and love them both and
I'm I'm so happy that I had both because
it opened my mind as well
um yeah which one do you
um
they're so similar
they're so yeah that's so interesting
yeah they're so similar I used to
actually go Church churches a lot um uh
again I don't please it's just my
opinion uh for me for me
my problem was I just didn't I couldn't
understand how like um Jesus was God so
now when and then when I've done my
research in Islam it was like he's a
prophet but so for me that made sense
and I thought okay like it answered my
question but they're just saying we need
to do good those tradition there is
respect for me
is the same I'm I'm curious because I've
noticed in Christian churches they're
kind of driving men out where there's
not a lot of young men in Christian
churches anymore it's like if you look
at them like if you go into a church
under like I don't know 35 ish it's
mostly women
um and I'm curious is are there more
young men in like Muslim religions
um from what I'm seeing now there's a
lot of converts I feel like
um there's there's more happening now so
um yeah I think there's there's loads of
man in in the mosque yeah because I
think it's one of the few religions that
that keeps traditional masculinity where
the Christians are kind of they're kind
of gone yeah because you know back in
the days it was it was so similar but
now people are trying to make it so
modern and it's like you can't pick and
choose yeah yeah yeah and they just like
Pander because most of the women are the
ones like paying into churches so the
problem is they just Pander to women
yeah and I've had like some Churches
like you can have gay marriages and
stuff you can't pick and shoot and the
other thing is they always have like
what do you call it um corn addiction
groups for the men but they never have
social media addiction groups for the
women and it's like they always like put
up women on a pedestal even if she's
like ran through and had two kids you
should still wait till you're married
with her it's like what are you why what
it's like something
okay I was just curious uh what about
you
um I know I'm average reason being is
because I'm not a wife yet I think the
best way to measure if someone is above
average is to look at their relationship
status and I feel like if a man hasn't
signed some papers and made a promise in
front of God to be with me forever and
have kids with me then that definitely
means I am an average woman it's like
going into singing competition and then
you know the judge is Whitney Houston if
Whitney Houston tells me I am not good
and that means I'm definitely you know
not above average when it comes to
singing so um yeah in terms of my
relationship status I'm still single I
haven't found anyone who is you know
ready to commit to me so that means
there's some things that I need to
improve on so yeah I'm average and I'm
happy about it it just goes to show that
I'm a work in progress and so what
you're gonna leave the value of yourself
in the hands of somebody else not at the
hands of someone else but it's just you
for me personally I feel like for me
personally I feel like a person's
ability to maintain a relationship goes
to show just how good of a person that
they are it shows their compatibility it
shows their patience and it also mirrors
how a person can value them as well so
for me I think relationship is the best
way to measure so for example if I saw a
woman and she was 50 with six cats I
would think there's something really
wrong with that woman who was like 20
and married like let's be real the best
way to measure how a person is like when
you see a female and she has like no
friends you would know there's something
wrong yeah those extreme examples are
valid so I definitely feel like the best
way to see how a person is you know a
good person is to see how they are with
their relationships and I feel like with
me marriage is that epitome of like okay
this person is a good person so yeah I
would say until I'm married I definitely
think I'm above her I think that's an
interesting perspective I think you're
right because it's like you have to
judge based on your results it's like
but I think like you as a woman the type
of guy you can maintain says something
about you so it's going to be a quality
husband
sorry I definitely agree with you in the
sense that like if you marry the wrong
person and that definitely means you're
average because how could you be so
silly to not realize what's best for you
so in that case but let's be real
there's a lot of marriages that have
worked out and for those that have
worked that I definitely think they are
above average because your ability to
keep someone happy to be patient to be
compatible to provide for them like for
me when I think of above average I think
of someone who's nurturing someone that
can cook someone that and when you
package that that's basically why female
traditional traditional women get
scooped up by 25 the best women are gone
by 25 out of the dating Market because
the best women want a family and want
kids and they find the man that want a
family and want kids and they're gone if
I could get married tomorrow about
absolutely weird honestly honestly
um but I definitely feel like Society
has lost that importance of like
measuring someone by their relationships
without being said 100 agree of what you
were saying but
on the lower scale a man can come along
and be absolute trash let me just use
like all right cool so
the way that my dad has worked yeah um
he's got with someone and he's married
them and it's like okay she's not worthy
he's just settled down with her because
it's convenient do you get what I'm
saying so if she was to measure that by
oh yeah I'm great you're not great babe
you don't have a lot going on but he's
married you because he's getting old and
because all of these different factors
on the larger scale what you're saying
100 I agree with you and it makes sense
but there are the uh the lower
percentage of men that are low quality I
just want to make it clear I think what
I was trying to say is if you're in a
healthy marriage I'm not going to sit
here and see if a guy
right right that means no there's
definitely some circumstances where
there's people that are married and they
are below average because again they're
abusive or the guy has set order
whatever yeah yeah but for the healthy
marriages and there's is a lot of
healthy marriages
um it definitely goes to show your
ability to be in a above average person
and another thing I realized I feel like
a lot of people focus too much on the
negative I feel like the negative
situations of abuse of Partners and
whatever they're like a small percentage
women are more abusive than men in 2023.
yeah I think there's more women that hit
men than men that hit women I just don't
think it's reported yeah I agree with
that actually because women hit men like
in this when they're angry and when
they're having arguments and they do
like pushing and shoving but the men
just don't retaliate so the thing is as
well for a man do you know how degrading
it is to bring up that your woman has
hit you exactly you're not going to
bring that up you're just going to keep
it quiet yeah so a lot of women they
brag oh you know my mum hit me a man
ain't gonna do that so it's very very
different and usually it's like the last
straw because you've actually got him to
that Peak at that point
they also don't talk about the women
that get a man to a certain point by
verbally abusing him and then he snaps
one day and then they label him as
abusive or crazy when it's like you
what's worse being hit like the scars
heal but things that people say to you
you can't take that back
um and can I also say that like sorry
and even if you are like an average
woman I think what we need to understand
like it's actually okay to be average
that basically just means you're a
working person so for everyone here he's
probably like single this is not me
trying to say that there's like
something wrong with you you're probably
still a work in progress just like me
and I think that's something like us as
people need to learn to admit a little
bit rather than just having this mindset
of okay I'm a cat today so now I'm gonna
be a cow I'm a dog like let's you can be
realistic in the present so yeah to
answer that question because I was kind
of waffling I'm definitely average yeah
but I think you know when you said about
like we focus on the negative like for
me personally like someone might say oh
you focus on the negative because I'm
not like definitely Keen to have a get
married and have kids right now and I've
always been that girl that's like live
your life travel do what you want like
tell my friends to women young girls
that I mean I'm like I'm very much an
advocate for that and then people may
think oh it's because you've never had a
healthy relationship in your life or
you've not got that example actually no
my parents have been together since they
were 16 and they're married and I live
with them so I have had the best example
actually but I have the most realistic
example as well but that's a modern
mindset that's a below average mindset
which which we'll travel and explore the
world no man don't want that yeah but
why is it about what men want because
like men are the buyers you have to
learn the buyers in order to be bought
yeah but I I just so I so strongly
disagree with that because I'm not going
to live my life depending on what a man
wants like and that's a below average
mindset that's a problem with modern
women
the men um no man wants a girl that
won't live here and when it's our skin
anyway let's ask him you're is that a
below average mindset because as a woman
I feel like it's important to you know
take care of yourself first when you're
young at least not I'm not talking when
you're older I'm saying you're like
early 20s teens like travel learn about
yourself and don't Focus so much on
trying to get into relationship and get
married by 25.
no I disagree you know I think I'd want
to be the one that takes her on that
experience so she experiences with me
for the first time
so you think that's a below average my
answer I'm still going to stand on my
point
S
no I'm just telling you how men see it
and like Nancy if you traveling around
Matt immensely that as you're sleeping
around like man then I will just wait so
men see it if you're in a different in
all these different cities that you're
writing something in all these different
cities that's how men see it it's also
if you've been single for a long time
men see it is oh she's been doing she's
been doing something she's been up to
something like that's how the guys see
it also and can I also sorry can I also
mention something you also mentioned how
your end goal is to be a wife and a
housewife and have kids so if that's
your end goal don't you think it is
important to consider how men are
viewing you
um yeah but it's like for example if my
end goal was my career then I would have
to focus on Career oriented things but
if your end goal is marriage and kids
don't you think you have to focus on how
men viewing because why can't I have a
career and have marriage and kids No but
I'm talking about like your end goal
like what you want as the end is it just
a career long term or is it yeah I think
marriaging kids will outweigh the career
for sure yeah so considering the fact
that like by 30 women's eggs start to
you know expire on whatever and you know
that is your end goal just all these
other factors you may lose your Youth
and Beauty wrinkles don't you think it's
important to consider what men would
think about you if that's your yeah it's
not like the right man who would not be
judging me because I've gone to France
and Spain like what the hell is that
about like like that that is just like
like the guy in whatever he just doesn't
care about this Social Media stuff he
just thinks it's a little crap like he's
met me and he probably had a few people
say like out of jealousy or whatever
because I'm a a popular figure certain
things and it's like no I'm gonna a
strong minded I need a strong-minded man
that's the thing I can't be dealing with
these men that'd be swayed by what they
hear by he she or her so if a man was
dating a hole Yeah does that make him
strong-minded because he actually does I
don't agree with that but it does I
think it's a strong mind no no no no no
no no no no no I'm just saying I
actually think it's I'm not saying I'm
not agreeing with men being with [__]
by the way that's what I'm saying I'm
saying but I do I actually do think it
is very strong-minded for a man to get
with one because he's clearly saying I
like you for you and despite what you've
done and what everybody says about you
I'm gonna stand by you and I can
actually respect that just that to a
degree and I've said it so many times
when I've seen people do it where I've
seen these men go for these women and
everyone's like why would he go for her
but maybe she is actually a good girl
like maybe good-hearted girl like maybe
she has made a lot of mistakes I think
do you think it's unwise knowing the
stats that I told you where there's only
a 20 chance that he'll be happy with her
in 10 years you don't think that's
simping a bit it's a bit unwind guys
no not if not if you want no no if your
son came to you for [__] would you be
happy with that of course not I just
told you I don't think I don't
necessarily agree if he came to you and
he said to your mom he's a good woman
and whatever and like it depends on how
um no I would say no personally because
I think there's enough women out there
for you to find a good woman that isn't
a [__] yeah I think you know what's so
funny in this like modern world
um it's either we have fun or I'm taking
it's like can you not be not find your
man and travel and learn like I think I
can enjoy my life and learn and have
knowledge and still have fun and still
enjoy my youth with a man
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it I feel like it's better to make
memories than you know have no memories
and getting and I've had experience and
he had experience you have memories of
your friends absolutely but I think it's
nice to have remember
that's not valuable to a guy though like
it's not valuable to a guy that you
remembering is about a guy
in order to have a happy marriage you
have to care what the man wants unless
if you want to do this like 50 50
partnership type [__] where your opinion
is like yeah you don't want to do that
right you want to be a housewife so if
you want to be a housewife only 20 of
women get to be Housewives so that means
that means it's competitive right now
girls are gonna get it and so like you
have to know the buyer in order to
compete and you also mentioned
it you also mentioned how you can do
both I have an example for you say for
example I wanted to have a six pack and
you know compete for the Olympics can I
do both things like be at McDonald's
every three times a week
because I've got a low metabolism what
I'm trying to say is that when you have
an end goal and you have an end point
when you focus on other things it
hinders you getting to that point so
what I'm trying to say is for the ladies
who's um you know your your goal is to
just to be a career woman I thought like
focusing on your career and traveling
that will work for you but if your end
goal is to like be your wife like I'm
saying your end goal that's what you
want when you settle down that you have
to make them steps to actually work
towards that yeah and I think that's
where Modern women get it like you know
messed up so going back to that example
like if my end goal is to have a
six-pack does that make sense to be
balancing McDonald's and salad
um you know the half of them it wouldn't
make sense but I disagree in that in
that sense I don't see anything wrong
with finding like you you know we we're
interested let's get married let's let's
grow up together I you know it's fine
there's nothing if you're young of
course you can still focus on University
or or your career but if you oh that's a
different story it's like you should
have had it it's too late now yeah but
you know it's fine it's fine in the
moment but when you're like 30 and
you're single like is it still gonna be
fine what do you mean so like you're
saying like having fun you're single
um
you said you want to be married you'd be
married absolutely how many dates do you
go on in a week
um
you don't okay so how on Earth would you
get the result of married if you don't
do anything to get there it's hard is he
just gonna magically find you at your
parents house
my brother yesterday's voice like look
fine
um I find it a bit hard because I I just
find I feel I think my husband is just
not in London you know okay so I feel
like it's a bit hard I feel like the way
I think and understand this in the way I
brought up I don't think they got the
same it's gonna be a bit harder for me
okay so so there's Instagram there's
dating apps where you can switch your
location there's matchmakers yeah like
how how on Earth would you get the
result of Mary I'm happy to get married
what is it called when um sorry arranged
marriage I'm happy no I'm happy if my
mom comes have you said to your parents
I want an arranged marriage I've set
this up and what do they say mom is
um mom is still looking for me mom is in
her own country right now finding me the
right husband some and it's better
because your parents will choose some my
mom doesn't want me to be in danger my
mom doesn't want to see me do bad yeah
but what if you've done so far well if
it's not your type you look at me you
think no for me for me I think marriage
about security is about creating a a
safe place for your child you have to be
attractive come on
I think the biggest problem I think for
me and you know that for me it's all
about character I can look at someone
like uh and then and you know they grow
to like and then back oh do you know
what yeah so I can't judge in the
beginning but what if he's not your type
though like generally that is an
arranged marriage as a surprise you
still need to be average you know
because this is this is actually the
reason like women end up single because
women in their 20s we typically select
for looks we're in our 30s
typically okay I'm not talking about you
typically in our 20 how tall is your
boyfriend
um he's like five eleven okay so so okay
so still top 20 height yes you do
um okay that's why they say you don't
listen to what women say watch what they
do
um okay so typically in our 20s like so
it's interesting because we're in a
monogamous Society technically that's
what we think but we're really in a
non-monogamous society because women
don't get married till the age of 31. so
we pick and women um who's in control of
sex
women women right so we pick
non-monogamy in our 20s which is when we
have the most to offer to men right and
we typically select for looks which is
the top 20 percent of men well when we
get to our 30s that's when we start
looking for security so then that
expands to the top like 50 60 percent of
men
um and so but basically what happens is
the top 20 percent of men run through
the girls in their 20s and then like we
pick the nice guy after
I think the biggest pandemic of today is
delusion I'm sorry to say yeah because I
feel like with women today we have this
idea on our head that the perfect guy is
just gonna drop on our laps and we're
just gonna get married when we want and
we don't realize that there's actual
actionable stuff
like everything in life you have to work
for it you have to make changes and it
kind of upsets me that sometimes people
have this idea in their head where just
like well I don't have to think about
this so I don't have to consider a man's
opinion and you kind of do it in order
to achieve any goal in life not just
relationships so I feel like yeah that's
just my point okay if if you're applying
for a job you don't care what the
employer thinks
yeah
you don't think a wife is a job
I do actually I think a housewife is a
job okay so I think it is so again you
don't have to care what the employer
thinks when you're looking to be happy
but that's that specific but then the
employer is putting I'm not I'm not
thinking about what the whole of Sony
thinks of me I'm thinking about what the
managing director of that department
thinks of me okay but you still have to
to figure out what they want right and
care about what they want to an extent
but it's not as rigid as that like it's
a relationship you know so I just feel
like it's not a relationship you
shouldn't care about what they want of
course you should okay so you do have to
yeah but how would you know that without
meeting them or just as human at this
point you talk to men and ask them what
they want no but you're saying like in a
sense that before as we're navigating
typically we want the same type of stuff
oh you talk about arranged marriage no
no I'm talking about like when you're
single and you're young you're
navigating you're traveling you're
saying I should be thinking as each each
day every step I take what all the men
on my Instagram are thinking of me as
I'm going to France as I'm doing this as
I'm doing it you know what I think it is
yeah of course carry yourself in the
best way I don't by the way I'm not I'm
not condoning like being a [__] and I'm
just saying the realistic thing of just
enjoying and living your life and
learning who you are before getting with
somebody because what you don't want is
to just get with somebody at 21 and then
you've never lived and then you get to
40 you realize you're not compatible you
never even lived your life what results
does that yield though as women as women
have pushed the age of marriage up and
up and up and found themselves before
the divorce rate goes up and up and up
so it doesn't like the results aren't
there did we not slightly as humans like
create this idea of marriage
where really it like obviously you see
in in the animal kingdom that's for
example you see a lot of obviously you
know the male line goes out and the
Lioness looks after the Cubs but that
lion wouldn't stay with that lioness
Warehouse apart from Penguins there's a
couple of little animals that do it but
you actually don't see monogamy really
in any other thing is this not something
that we've created out of religion out
of uh like this is not something that
you think
I don't know
actually I talked to a biologist or he
wrote this book called the history of
sex the other day so I'm trying to
recite it right but he basically said
that when we were
um more intertwined with like animals
because like we came from like chimps or
whatever it was super non-monogamous but
actually the majority of human history
has been monogamous for 85 percent of
the population however the top 15
percent of women um are the top 15
percent of men have been a
non-monogamous relationship so
um essentially now the top like we're
going more towards non-monogamy because
again women are choosing non-monogamy in
their 20s where most women used to pick
monogamy but that's not something that
we created like I don't think was that
something that we actually used through
thousands and thousands of years you go
right back to you know the Romans when
they had wives I mean it's not something
that
it's something that's actually baffled
me for a long time like you actually
agree on your kingdom where else do you
actually see this idea of marriage and
and when you actually look at it a lot
of it has come when you when you go and
get married it's in a church or a union
in Thailand it's it's in a temple so it
a lot of it comes down to something I
just think it's the best for building
families and I think it's I honestly
think it's a natural like at least from
women to men I don't know I'm just I was
just gonna come out I don't I don't know
any animal that really it's actually
it's actually because
um this kind of constructs are necessary
for society to exist
because without us being monogamous and
all of that if you were to look in the
animal kingdom where monogamy doesn't
exist the males have to fight each other
usually to the death to get sex and
human beings can't function in that way
because what then happens what's
interesting is that Society can't stand
so that's the reason it's not so that's
the fair point but then again is this
not again something it's still
constructed so that doesn't deny the
Temptation or the ability to then look
elsewhere but you know I mean you've
been consciously aware that that we
wouldn't be able to
functions
so it used to be a compromise of our
mating strategies like what's what's the
female mating strategy to get the best
guy you possibly can right to get the
best genes right or the best resources
right that's women to get attention from
from that right so um it used to be that
like women would bring Purity in you so
they would come to the like marriage and
they would say I'm not going to sleep
with anyone else and I'm going to stay
with you for your lifetime and I'm not
going like I'm not going to try to go
higher and higher and higher and the men
used to come in and say you know I'm not
going to sleep with anyone else because
their mating strategy is to sleep with a
bunch of different women so it used to
be a compromise but the problem is women
don't bring Purity anymore because what
percent of women are virgins so it's
kind of an unequal exchange because no
most men out earn most women most men
still have to protect most women but
women don't bring the Purity or the
youth and like that's why I think we see
men walking away from marriage because
like honestly women like what what do
modern women bring to the table not much
what percent of women have the skills of
our grand or grandmothers and great
grandmothers where we can we have a full
cookbook and we can cook where we're
virgins where we um you know we can sow
guard like all of the traditional skills
women don't have anymore but the problem
is women still want to be courted like
traditional women even though I do agree
I think to answer that and the funny
thing is as well now when it gets hard
they're running away so you get married
back in the days they will work and work
and work until we can make it and that's
why women bring less to the table
because that used to be the thing that
the man got even if she wasn't a virgin
he's like you know if we get married she
cannot leave me but now 80 of women are
80 of women half of marriages end in
divorce and women leave 80 children with
them they take the kids and they're my
so that's why we see less and less men
getting married today but we also have
to look at why is the the generation
Society also not teaching you in schools
what are they teaching you they're not
teaching you how to how to how to watch
how to sew how to do all of these things
as a woman so when you come out of
school you don't know what you're doing
your mum and your dad's not together do
you know what I mean no I think I think
there's an agenda right but but it still
doesn't change the product yeah and and
the truth is the product of of women as
a whole is just worse than ever before
and I agree and also factor in the fact
that everything is very convenient so
like you've got a dishwasher you've got
you've you can just get the road
everything has changed you don't even
have to have those skills anymore
because it's not it's not a necessity
back then it was a necessity to have
these skills yeah but the problem is
like what kind of I disagree with it and
I wish it was like that that's the thing
I'm actually super old school in so many
ways like I wish so many of the habits
we had today would just convert back to
how it was I don't actually like the way
things are going I don't so but just
have to also be aware of what what we
have right now and also to answer your
questions about whether it was created I
don't think it was something that was
created I think it's something that's
just natural and just work I think what
was created was that idea to actually go
against it and go against the family
structure I think that's what has been
that's what's happened and I feel like
if we go back to like just statistics if
we look at modern society today and you
know how that divorce rates are um
Skyward skyrocketing what has that done
to society like Society is literally
falling apart I mean so I feel like it's
something that's natural and it's
something that works and it's definitely
not something that just we just decided
let's just create it
that's all been done for a reason
exactly because your kids are getting
taken away from you from young for a
reason there's a reason why dishwashers
and all of these things have been
created is to split up the families so
that they can take you on board and they
can raise you to what they want you to
be exactly do you get what I'm saying so
now you're not with your husband and
your and your children raising them how
you want take them from young for me for
me I think you don't get to be a
traditional woman anymore I think for me
no I think women choose not to be
traditional women that is true but it's
also a bit of both no no I think I think
women kind of use excuses for yeah yeah
yeah like okay I'll give you an example
one in three women have had an abortion
hmm do traditional women go abort their
children they wouldn't have done that no
and so it's like those those are like we
constantly make Choice after Choice
after choice that makes us less all by
yourself even if you're you get out in
the world at 18 there's nothing stopping
you from learning how to cook learning
how to clean so you know studying what
men want yeah and study what women want
all the time there's a million
self-improvement things for guys there's
a million dating courses for guys all
the women dating like self-help [__]
it's literally just reaffirming women
there's no actual actionable steps it's
just like be confident yeah and Society
can lead you to be exactly what I just
said but then on the other hand it's
what you just said it's for you to fight
for what's right you can either go down
the easy path or the hard path up to you
and what you choose to do as a woman I
think like feminists from what is it
called feminism feminism has ruined a
lot of like traditional women and as has
ruined us as well
um I'll give an example even like
working I'll give an example working
um now I'm working as them as a mom and
you're working as a dad sorry she's
gonna take care of the kids yeah exactly
now someone else is going to program our
children and not just that I'm paying
tax and he's paying tax is is we're
trapped it's it's not supposed to right
yeah that's why I think being like a
housewife when you have kids is actually
essential like I think that is so
important to just be with your kids
during those at least during those first
like very incremental years of their
lives like I'm not saying it just for
sure I'm saying because I actually want
to look after you my kids the thing is
women have always worked they just
worked in the home true and the man
like they think they're just going to do
nothing as a house but it's so true you
know what I our grandmothers great
grandmothers had to maybe great great
grandmother's great great like they
worked on the farm yeah I want an
allotment I want like all of this when I
at my house like I'm not here you're
going to be sitting listen I don't even
do that now I don't sit on my ass that's
the thing so I know what I bring to the
table I I cater to my man literally and
every day and age you have social media
as well so if you're sitting at home as
a as a you know stay-at-home mum yeah
you can also have your own business so
you can there's so many things that you
can do how do you how do you cater to
your man if you don't care what men want
because I don't care what other men want
I care what he wants yeah but that's
better the same well he's not
I have a question for you if you think
you're an average woman why wouldn't you
date an average man like a bus driver
that's an average man the reason why is
because I don't aspire to stay average
that's why that's why I am I want to
become an above average person so if I
just date an average man more than
likely we are going to stay on that
level yeah but how old are you so you're
23 23 yeah you're only going to get less
average from now you're not going to get
better do you think so no you're I mean
women fertility you're just going to get
less and less fertile the older you get
like if you look at women on dating apps
like half of your options are gone by 30
like half of the options you have at
like 21 or 22. if you look at like men
from the ages of 20 to 80 they ask them
what age they find women the most
attractive it's like 22 23. and uh some
say 18 some say lower than 18 but if you
don't tell them the age but like
actually yeah it's just gonna get worse
like you you have the most value you're
ever gonna have about now really yes I
mean personally I feel like I'm doing
that work right now there's nothing
where I'm just sitting on my bum just
doing nothing not trying to manage
myself I'm definitely doing the work now
and I'm hopeful of the fact that I will
actually find someone because
um yeah that's what I definitely feel
like I will find someone before that
time I'm not like a silly girl that just
sits down and does nothing I'm realistic
I know the action will build steps that
I need to take I'm taking those steps
and it's definitely working for me and
I'm curious what steps are you taking so
one thing I'm definitely trying to do is
lose weight I definitely want to get in
shape another thing I'm trying to do is
I want to learn how to cook especially
traditional food another thing I'm
trying to do is grow closer with God as
well I feel like you know when you're
closer to God that's when you actually
reach your peak of femininity and uh how
much weight do you want to lose I'm a
size 12 right now I want to be a size 10
size 10. yeah Okay and like how much do
you cook in a week how much should I
cook I cook once a week only because I
work from no yeah I cook once a week
um yeah it's not like my cooking skills
are bad I just want to my cookings goes
actually good when would you like to
have lost the weight by I want to lose
it by the end of this year okay you can
come back end of this year yeah I'll be
skinny size then come back we do we're
pro self-improvement here so no I think
that's great but I just think a lot of
times like like women we always think
we're gonna get better tomorrow and when
like honestly it's better to cash out
when you're young I think that's what I
do yeah I think that's what I'm doing do
you mean like if you find somebody just
hold on to them yeah yeah I would agree
yeah because the other thing let's let's
show can we bring up the same video same
video of the girl I just want to point
something out
um I just want to show them like I just
want her picture that's all I want on
the screen like I'm not gonna play it
the the one we were watching before
um it can be the second one too if you
want I just wanted to picture the girl
okay you see how old do you guys think
she is
terrible wife I'm blindish that's me
getting older all right so actually
first first I want to say what do you
rank that girl one to ten
I think she's really pretty okay she's
gorgeous I think she'll be like an eight
yeah her Ages was hindering her but yeah
you can tell she's an older lady but
she's very attractive yeah I want to
hear from the guy
what do you grade her one to ten
actually I want to hear from you oh can
every guy zoom in okay wait wait
actually wait wait
um I'm gonna have all the girls read her
and then I'm gonna have the guys reader
so you said a does anyone think she's
lower than an eight I still can't see
her face I need to zoom in well
obviously basing it purely on just her
face right yeah you guys saw her earlier
right in the other video
play it for a second just so you can see
your face 50 000 plus comment posted on
social I only saw a handful that even
considered the possibility of a bus
owner being a more aspirational position
and recognizing that I am actually
speaking and you can pause it okay so
one one to ten no I'm gonna I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say seven seven I'm gonna
say okay I'm so sorry I literally cannot
see her face yeah can you zoom in king
or can you Google her maybe
uh let's see
I think it's in the title
[Music]
ebony Williams ivani K1 sorry if I said
that wrong I don't pronounce names well
okay last thing can you move for a sec
um can you zoom in at all
oh here we go
are you able to can you guys see her now
yeah I'd say seven okay I'd say like a
solid seven there okay uh all right what
do you think I would say an eight eight
okay what do you think seven seven okay
no no no no not guys yet you I said
seven seven I still can't see but I
think she's really cute she's got a cute
face cute nose yeah I'd say maybe eight
yeah eight okay let's say about eight
yeah eight I think seven seven okay so
the cons I think there's more eighths
than this like 7.5 is the average okay
what do you what do you rate her this
just appearance wise yeah appearance
that's seven back in the day she
probably was like a nine okay seven King
what do you reader
come on
six six okay what do you guys reader
six
six okay so the guy I say six they're
mostly six six point two something what
are you right here
well
um
so how old do you guys think she is she
looks 40.
yeah I think she's probably about 40 but
she looks a bit younger
yeah so she's 39. so because she's 39
I'd say she's like a five yes oh really
yeah yeah I think look based on my hair
looks though not her age but age pays a
part yeah age kind of plays a part so
what you really think she's a five when
you look at her yeah
she was 20 what would you rate her
eight but she's not 20. she's 40. that's
not based on Alexa that's based on her
age
on her picture well I think she looks
old she doesn't look a bit older
the younger that you go the higher you'd
rate her yeah so basically old people
are not cute to you basically both
people can't be beautiful
oh people can't go above five no no no
no no old women can't go women are not
as cute yeah old man a man age like wine
women age like
oh
[Music]
wait wait wait wait until wait guys guys
stop stop
um so this is the thing women insert
exception this one woman that looks good
it's like
come on but if most of the people in the
room would rate her a 78 and it's only
you that's raid her five doesn't that
make her pretty hard most of them rated
her sex so mine's slightly lower so like
six that's about five so wouldn't she be
above average or pretty since most of us
if we're speaking on a general sense
yeah I mean you could you could say six
but like that's not that different than
a five I just think when you're 40 it's
like minus a point I think there's like
your looks and then you lose a point
when you're old that's that's what I
think is it something like like as as
women like we're all pretty similar ages
but is it something like as women like
we're we're aware of feeling like less
beautiful as we get older like yeah
definitely okay do you guys think you're
getting prettier the older you get
you probably can't really have children
like what can you really like provide as
a woman if you can't make babies
yeah but then looks brings an age so
when you see it but what if you're 20
and you look old
because I've seen that a lot yeah or if
you're 40 and you look yeah yeah
because I've seen that I just and I
looked younger as I've got older
actually we could talk about exceptions
and we can talk about the rule like most
people look their age you know
um but yeah so my question is what does
a 39 year old
single woman why does she feel
comfortable sitting on a bus driver I
think because
when the men say she's a six roughly and
she kids is out the window so I mean
because like as a guy I'm assuming right
you guys can tell me if I'm wrong you're
gonna go down a point in terms of
marketability to you because she can't
have kids yeah yeah at
um and the relationship because the
person was a few years older than me and
I knew that there was going to be a
future there by the time I was ready she
wasn't gonna be ready yeah I mean so
it's definitely a fact though yeah so
why why are we in a society where an
average check is [__] on average man
because we're making more I think the
reason why she can say that is because
obviously she's in an established
position so hence why like you said
women always go for men that are doing
better than them so definitely a bus
driver would be her down downgrading
herself yeah understand the age Factor
but at the end of the day she's
successful so she should deserve to go
for someone that's more successful than
her completely yeah
I disagree I I think it's like what what
is your marketability to men
so so you can you can go after the men
that make more than you but I think
that's a recipe to die alone if you
can't get the men that make more than
you then you have to go down and you
have to respect him but then the
relationship's not gonna work because
she's with someone that's broken in her
like any guy who is broken then broke
men are so sad and depressed and
dangerous yeah like she's gonna be in an
unhappy relationship an average like a
bus driver like he's broke he's not
broken
but see this this is the problem with
our mentality as women we care more
about the lifestyle than the family
because all we're thinking about is the
money well he's broker than me but I
feel like what percent what percent of
women are gonna give up their careers
for a family what percent of women are
going to give up their Lifestyles for a
family I think him being a bus driver
sorry I think him being the bus driver
that will contribute to the the family
aspect because if a man is making less
than the girl and can't provide he's
gonna feel inferior so therefore the
marriage is eventually going to break
down I don't think that I think it's
more that the woman
I've gone for guys that make less than
me but it's like if you don't treat them
like they do they like they don't feel
it yeah and it's like if you're not
super snotty and asking for like all
these crazy [__] as entitled to their
preference of like what they want and
like it's correct Everyone's entitled
for what they want but it's a recipe to
die alone like this is what would you
rather be have a bunch of money and be
by yourself or have a family but what
does she do like is she just to present
on she's like a newscaster and it's and
it's funny because her job is completely
like you don't Society doesn't need it
to run so it's like I don't understand
as women why we come off thinking we're
so much better than the men when our
jobs aren't even needed in society to
run like a bus driver the society needs
to run but I think because maybe has
like desire for like not even desire
story maybe her like this regard for a
bus driver probably just stems from the
fact that maybe this was her ambition
like you know how you said your anger is
to like marriage and kids I think that's
maybe most girls's end goal maybe she
her dream was to be a presenter or a
news report or something like that and
she's clearly 39 no kids no man like I
think she sacrificed she's made
sacrifices to be in a position like if
this was her end goal then she's clearly
sacrificed a lot like 40 years of work
maybe like to get into this position so
I wouldn't blame it like if that was
really the angle I wouldn't blame her
for disregarding a bus driver because
it's like she's fought with no kids like
why would she go back I think if you're
a woman and like that's the position you
choose to put yourself in you have to
date down and be happy with it I don't
think because otherwise don't put
yourself in that position because what
what percent of men like make six
figures
maybe she's not um like [__] on the
the salary I think just in the word
itself bus driver sounds like manual
labor it sounds like I don't want to
date what's wrong with manual labor no
but that's the thing is like bus drivers
like this is what I'm saying is like
I've seen a bus so many times like 15
pounds like if I went on indeed and saw
15 pound an hour job I would not mind
but it's something about driving a big
red bus for me personally I just find it
I wouldn't even sound embarrassing
because there's people who drive buses
but if I'm a news reporter and you'll
hope like there's people like tap in the
Oyster called the school kids at 3 P.M
on your bus and I'm here reporting
globally like oh my gosh the king's been
coronated then my man is driving kids
from school so like what it's like get
off your high horse you talk I talk for
a living you're just talking but this is
what I'm saying I don't think I don't
think it's actually like the way I
personally think it's just the position
because if you say there's 15 an hour
like a musician Maybe
I know and I think that's the problem is
average women like [__] on average men
and we act like we're better than them
when we're not no I don't yeah I think I
think I've actually I think I've
actually been
like subject to doing that like to
actually thinking that I deserve more
than what I can give to you or what I
like exactly that what I bring to the
table which is which is different for
both because because you're a really
successful musician because you've been
on like X Factor or whatever right so
it's like if you put yourself in the top
10 of of talent right and that's great
but you you have to know what's come
what comes with it and it doesn't make
you more attractive to men men don't
care it's nothing and so it's like women
will treat their career and act like
it's an asset to men when it's nothing
you're still an average chick
[Music]
um how old are you I'm 26 26. do you
have babies or I wish I'm trying do you
have a husband no no no ring but no and
and it's true to me too it comes with
like I could tell you because I'm in
that situation it comes with a lot of
problems you can't look like you're
better than these men you have to speak
from experience that's it yeah I just
think the preference thing and like
Everyone's entitled to what they think
they desire and deserve yeah and the
standard that they want for their life I
don't agree with [__] on people like
I don't agree with that I'm so against
that actually like I don't I wouldn't
say she really shot on the bus driver
she just answered the question
yeah yeah bus driver he's out the door
without asking any other questions and
I'm saying that's the problem
if she was younger maybe but you're so
old like
actually you can't what are you gonna if
I was a man I'd be like what can you
provide for me you can't even make
babies she doesn't want babies and what
if he doesn't want babies she can find
somebody on the same level
why would a man why would a man marry a
39 year old that can't offer him
children like because he might have had
his kids like surely she's 39 she's
gonna probably go for someone that's
about 50 55.
but then why would he get married at all
he might you might not get married
that's my and that's it is marriage the
epitome of success I think I think as a
woman yeah I think I think you're a
loser if you don't get married and have
kids
equivalent of not getting married and
having kids I think the equivalent of
that is as a guy that doesn't have a job
as well that I think you have to
consider because you said that she might
want to date someone that's like maybe
55. 55 year old bus driver but a 39 year
old TV presenter I feel like is not the
same I feel like realistically the bus
driver is not going to be like 20 years
old he's probably going to be older so
it's slightly more embarrassing that
within your life you didn't build a
better career right but why does it
matter if you have money so she has
money because she's actually women like
naturally like natural selection or
whatever like naturally women feel more
secure with a guy who has more money but
this is the problem it's like she's not
a traditional woman how many bodies she
got by 39. well this is an assumption oh
come on 30 you're telling me 20 years in
the dating Market but even if she does
even if she does like I don't think that
now that lowers your value to men it
makes you less valuable so so the whole
point is she wants a traditional outcome
but she's not a traditional woman we
don't know that yet I don't know that
yet
I think so I think a lot of people
and I noticed it everyone just ignored
the fact that she's this quote-unquote
high value woman that ends this amount
of money and this and that and she's
around a lot of high value men so why
haven't any of them picked her that's
very interesting and um I only say that
because I grow with I grew up with my
brother and I can think like a man
um so with my brother what I understood
how men think is the older you get how
men think that the more experience you
have whether you do or don't only you
and God knows it doesn't matter but the
older you get the way American view you
is like you have a lot of experience why
are you single why are you so old more
the older you get you have more
experience it's harder to change you the
older that you get so a man will go for
a younger woman because they're able to
manipulate we can view it in a bad way
or we can view it as they're able to
because I know if I was a man I'd get
with someone younger so that I can mold
them to what I want them to be now you
look and sit there and be like oh you
know he's manipulates grooming all right
cool but actually
I know that if I go for a 30 year old
woman they're going to be stuck in their
ways if you both smoke I've got a 20
year old woman there 30 year old woman
there both of you smoke
I can actually probably change the 20
year old woman but a 30 year old I don't
think
two are supposed to become one flesh
anyways right right so and that's like
that's how they used to view it I think
they were one yeah I think the main
question here is if she was to date a
bus driver will the relationship work no
one won't work because he's not
providing for her he's not being the
superior person in the relationship so
what's the point of her going for a bus
driver what for the sake of seeing she
has babies I think she knows it's just
not going to work like a bus driver
probably doesn't know as much as her
probably hasn't had as much experience
as her they probably do not have the
same thing in common in terms of media
so she actually talks for a living yeah
but she probably has experience of like
she's probably in big rooms with people
they have like really serious
conversations she probably can't have
them conversations of a bus driver so I
think the reason why she's saying that
is because she knows with a bus driver
the relationship is just not gonna work
I'm sure you can agree that a man's
roles to provide right so if he can't
provide the relationship is just it's
not gonna work I think in his role is to
provide if you're a traditional woman if
you deserve to be provided for so as a
traditional woman I mean like State like
what is that I think I think in general
like what our great grandmothers were
our grandmas
imagine
more so yeah yeah I mean I really don't
think they exist anymore to be honest
but like virgin
um usually like submissive to their
husband Cooks cleans no good with
children has experience with children no
sewing isn't like I think we know in
general what a traditional woman is like
we're not we're not dumb you know so
um I I think it's entitled to ask for
something you don't deserve and that's
why I think this is crazy because she's
asking for something she doesn't deserve
she's asking for traditional treatment
when she doesn't deserve it I think
that's a bit harsh to say that she's
entitled only because obviously when you
compare it to like traditional women the
grandmothers and stuff like that they
didn't have an option to become a TV
presenter their whole life goal was to
be a housewife and have race kids like
women have been able to work since like
the 20s no but this is what I'm saying
is that like where can TV presenters two
different things like this woman is on
TV every day she's having fun she's
living her dream she's kicking back like
I personally if I'm on TV having fun I
don't really know at 39 I'd want to come
back to a however year old bus driver
but he's probably riding his bus and
he's going to be so happy to see you
know his pretty wife on the TV and he
comes home and he sees her as well I
feel like this is better a bus driver
error
so you come home right and you lay in
bed and there's air
but you know that's different and
there's ore or there's a bus driver or
the equivalent of an average job because
she's an average chick but that's what
I'm saying he's asking me like if if
like if he's getting on my nerves I'd
rather air but I feel like bus drivers
work long hours anyway so 90 of the time
is probably going to be airing that bed
but I just feel like it's harsh for her
to be entitled just because men like so
she's 40 right what does life look like
for her at 60 70. like we're supposed to
live to be 90 years old what is she
gonna do the last 40 years of her life
her looks are gone so TV's over I don't
know she doesn't she's invisible to men
because like men aren't really checking
for women over the age of like 45 50 you
know 50 if you're lucky
um so now what is the second half of her
life look like the thing is is obviously
personally like I don't know but
obviously she said she just doesn't want
to spend it with a bus driver so if
that's what sis doesn't want then that's
what sis doesn't want and maybe like who
knows maybe that debate actually sparked
up and woke up a bus driver and he's
thinking you know what I'm really gonna
work harder or maybe you know what
they're like [__] it she's 40 I can't
really I'm gonna keep driving my bus
like but my point my point isn't even
really hurt like I don't I don't really
give a [__] about this girl right my
point is like average women still feel
entitled to above average men and we're
so delusional to think that we are going
to get them when what does she bring to
the table as a 39 year old news
presenter so would you say in the bus
drivers above average and she's average
I'm saying she's average
um maybe even below average at 40. as
into what she can bring to a guy and a
bus driver is an average man so they're
like equals kind of yeah and she thinks
she's above it so what about men so Paul
would you um marry a Tina
do you guys think you guys would have a
lot in common
it's funny I actually want to date
someone I like prefer it when we have
nothing in common so how would the
relationship survive like what would you
guys discuss if you guys I don't I don't
really think you need to talk yeah
so then that would basically be like
dating air exactly no I feel like you
should talk to her I was thinking about
this the other day I was like do men
really want to listen to us talk
absolutely you know I have deep
conversations you have to really just
talk to my friends and not you just
never talk I think it's very attractive
when you the partner and they've got
something
yeah
oh did you remember what my friend they
don't want to hear that but if it's
something learning knowledgeable thank
you
um yeah absolutely that's that's what
they I think that's why I'm saying like
what's the news reporter we're gonna
learn from a bus driver
but when you think about it is like when
you just look at it she obviously she
reports the news like in general she
just comes across she might know a lot
more but obviously he might end up
learning way more from her because
obviously she reports things exactly
vice versa it's kind of Vice Versa but
at the same time he's probably gonna
learn more from her than she will from
him so it's like in that sense she kind
of is valid to like you know maybe she
wants to like learn from her partner
like maybe that's why she doesn't want a
bus driver I feel like she could date a
lawyer or she could date a shopkeeper or
she could date a teacher but a bus
driver like let's be real like there's
actual levels to things in this life and
I feel like that's they would have
absolutely nothing in common and I'm not
even judging it due to his pockets I'm
judging this actually the compatibility
what are they going to talk about it
what they're going to discuss what
they're going to have in common yeah I
feel like in that aspect she's allowed
to say that this is not going to work
and she's better off dating again
in history people didn't have anything
in common like his story like having
similar hobbies to a guy that's a new
thing no you have to have something okay
okay so hunter-gatherer what what did
they have in common survival
okay even on the farm like they did
different roles like having similar
interests is a new thing
yeah but I'm saying they both did
different roles on the farm like they
didn't do the same things like the woman
was more in the house the guy was more
in the field but managing that whole
property that that was what they had
right they had the family in common and
so you would still have the family in
common in this situation but we're
talking a lot about like traditional
women but I just want to understand like
you guys's thoughts on traditional men
and how common that is these days do you
feel like it's common as well that do
men play their part do they play their
position I think that there's more
traditional men than traditional women
um okay and then can we just go over
what a traditional man is just in brief
just um I would say a guy that wants to
protect and provide
um I think I've been researching more
about like guys providing
um and I don't know what what 50 to 60
000 is in the UK but you can actually
live off of a lot of 50 to 60 000 that's
about what like 4 TK yeah so on 40K um
you can feed roughly a family of four or
five if you if you do it right
in London you might have to go to the
suburbs yeah that's what I'm saying like
you can homeschool the kids if you want
and you go out into the suburbs and he
commutes to work you can do it people
just don't want to the thing is most
guys naturally want to be providers and
protectors but most women set standards
that are way too high for most men to
meet that's the issue okay can you give
us an example of a standard that's high
too high okay can I can I give you one
yeah if you want to have your nails done
the rest of your life yes and you want
makeup the rest of your life would could
you go without that expense for a family
of course for a family a lot of women
won't
I've heard your perspective on the
makeup day a lot of a lot of women like
won't go down in lifestyle for a family
I would do that for my family I know you
you might you might but I'm saying like
a lot of women won't because I was
speaking to a woman who raised like four
or five kids on like 40 to 50K and she
was like giving examples of jobs you can
go for and I I can't remember it exactly
but she was giving examples like for
women of jobs you can go for in like
places you can find those men and like
how you can do it and she's like you
only like when you go down to one income
it's less money and if you homeschool
the kids it's less money if you grow
your own food it's the funny less money
but like most people refuse to do that
now that's interesting but even on the
thing about maintaining like appearances
and stuff makeup knows like for me
personally like I believe in enhancing
what you naturally have so yeah I've got
makeup on I actually don't wear that
much makeup I don't have eyelashes on I
wear mascara these are my these are my
real nails no no no I'm just saying as
an example of the fact that I take time
to actually look after my natural
qualities so if I didn't to like come
off it I can not wear makeup tomorrow
and I couldn't get my nails done
tomorrow and if all the shops ended and
everything all of this I could survive
and look good naturally I take care of
myself like I I look after myself so
that's why I think women need to
concentrate on more than just adding on
things women make 80 of consumer buying
decisions like women are bad with money
bad like think about it metal that means
men only spend 20 of like what is it
because of the appearances right no I
think it's because women were more
impulsive and we just make more
emotional decisions yeah probably I
think when it comes to maintenance and
things I think every woman should look
after themselves I think the mistake
that us females make is we spend too
much money looking after themselves like
there's so many ways to look nice and do
it on a budget like for example with me
I've always been a girly girl I've
always loved fashion and when I got like
my first few jobs I used to spend so
much money on clothes and would have
nothing left then I decided let me just
be a fashion influencer and I haven't
spent money on clothes in like the last
three years so there's and even as well
sometimes I resell those clothes so
there's smart ways to look good but
actually do it on a budget so for all
the girls watching this I strongly
encourage you to not fall into that
pressure or feeling like you have to
spend thousands every month just to look
good because you really don't the woman
I spoke to said she spent I think it was
less than 100 a year and clothes for
five kids because they would do resales
and hand-me-downs but her kids that
takes a lot of time and patience I guess
correct but like most women don't want
to do it yeah
it's important for men though as well do
you think yeah I do actually have
importance I do not as important not as
important not as important I feel like
hygiene is definitely important because
no one wants a smelly man but the reason
why is not important because for women
that's not what we look for I feel like
our main priority is someone like
emotions and provide you know not
someone that's going to be aesthetically
pleasing to us and that's the problem of
society today men care more about Gucci
than actually going out and having an
elephant man caring more about Gucci
yeah men care more about Gucci and
having an LV belt and looking nice than
actually you know going out and having a
job again the numbers just don't support
you because men aren't really spending
money like that
I think Modern Men especially men in my
generation no I'm telling you if you
look at the numbers of like the money
spent it's not it's women that are
spending money it's not men there might
be like exceptions but again you
probably you guys don't see 80 of men
like they're invisible to you you don't
notice the guy at Tesco you don't notice
the guy and I'm
like I'm I'm saying like for most of it
you find 80 of men is unattractive well
statistics don't lie so I can't even
argue that yeah no I think it's
important for a man to take care of
himself but just to answer your question
like if you're talking like getting like
facials or just skin care skincare is so
important like across the board I think
we all need to take that seriously men
manicures pedicures that's great do that
I'm gonna Read Super chats
wait wait I'm gonna Read Super chats for
a second
um okay uh Sergey dating a bus driver
doesn't mean she'll live in a bus um
Sergio it's sad some of these girls will
end up alone
um and wish they had a bus driver I bet
a bus driver knows more about life and
people than these girls Cameron average
women are better than average Men by
objective standards the delusion of this
show is that average men are meant to
reproduce everyone plays their part on a
bell curve like it or not Israel a
modern women are finished interracial
interracial relationships a problem with
modern women is how they can dismiss
regard and minimize contributions men
provide to women no amount of money can
buy a good man and no woman is entitled
to a relationship
um ex eccentric nightmares falling feels
like flying until you hit the ground
these ladies are falling um and the
ground is approaching Alona how do you
ladies nurture I'm your man when he's
struggling to reach his goals examples
of times you wanted to object or
complain about a man's Choice um for you
too but instead supported equal
submissive give us examples I want to
add that actually to my list of
questions I ask people it's a good one
um Bella um Q
um you've been ran through a lot I mean
you have been with many men have been
damaged mentally emotionally physically
um that
uh that's not above average tell me
something else
um wait sorry guys
question for the panel do you believe in
happy La happy wife happy life why or
why not uh d
um can you remember that King for when
I'm done okay D um when I hear I am the
table at this point I'm hearing I bring
nothing other than problems and drama I
see broken tables with everyone chewing
gum stuck to the bottom hey Pearl
um hi D Dragon stallion1001 you may be
the table but the man brought the house
to the table that brought the house the
table sits and stops thinking you're
special you're not Amina and my culture
virgin girls have a religion Beauty then
she is above average if she has Beauty
but she's not a virgin I'm not religious
then she's not valued by men
um Cameron um are you even interested in
modern solutions Pearl you bottled that
dude last show and he was so mid
compared to the other guests the UK
Economist please ask why do women who
grew up in average working class
communities believe they're entitled to
high earning men in a higher class the
clue Channel homeschooling is communal
Pearl don't look at don't look at home
schooling
um as you're teaching the courses to
your children by yourself the clue
Channel another w you
I'll wear that this is from my last
stream Let me refresh it
um
Gus um can't believe you 304 is a base
of man's masculinity on job title people
confuse education with intelligence you
can have a bachelor's degree and still
be an idiot invest in animal food wine
and IVF
um winter summer Pearl according to
direct directions Credit Union here's
what they found overall spending
um single men outspent
uh single men outspent single women men
spent an average of 41 208 a year as
opposed to 38 838 by women oh that's
interesting I'd be curious because I
know that men only make 20 of consumer
buying decisions so I'm actually curious
how that would work
um Sergey Bernard I'm dating a bus
driver doesn't mean she'll live in the
bus
um I could be wrong though let me you
can send that to me
um
guys what was the question that they
asked
I know someone submitted one I don't
remember what it was
foreign
[Laughter]
oh here I found it okay do you guys
believe in happy wife happy life why or
why not
yes
I believe that
um the wife basically is in charge of
the household
um not the household but the house in
itself so if the wife is in a bad mood
or is not doing okay the kids are not
going to do okay like for example with
me when my mom was you know going
through things or upset she wasn't able
to nurture us the way she could and
sometimes that would affect us not in a
big way so imagine if you know a woman
is not happy in a relationship she's not
able to do her wifely duties properly so
therefore the woman's life the kid's
life and the man's life is not going to
be able to like you know well the way I
see I feel like the wife is the Son and
everything orbits around it and she's
what keeps things moving so if that's
not working out nothing else is going to
work out
[Music]
I think it's not fair to say like happy
wife happy life I feel like we should
make a man happy as well because they
they can like he's the one that's
providing he's the one that's taking
care of the household he's the one
that's making you feel safe he he he we
will want to do stuff as well we put
stuff on the table I'm speaking about
him now I feel like her happy husband
happy life and happy wife happy life
both of them what do you think I feel
like happiness is just a feeling and you
know like for I don't know what's that
for a woman but for a man when we wake
up sometimes I'm not happy but I have to
keep it moving because I've got I've got
stuff to do whereas in the past I've
been a partner as soon as something goes
wrong and she's not happy it all breaks
down and you have to come up with a
solution so in that sense there's so
many more like different things for like
uh about like a female to be unhappy
about something I don't really have that
choice I don't have that that um
pleasure to have that feeling if you
know what I mean but at the same time
I've been married so I don't know from
other people that have told me did they
say that what do you think
um I would agree I think it's about 60
50 about 60 to the woman 50 I'm sorry 60
40. I'm a bit tired
um 40 to the the man because I would say
because obviously biologically women are
just a lot more emotional naturally so I
feel like the repercussions of her
unhappiness will affect a lot more than
the repercussions of a man's unhappiness
as in he could probably hold it together
a bit uh More Than a Woman
um it's not going to impact as much and
to Echo what you said about the kids in
the household it's gonna affect all of
that and that's now your environment so
I feel like that's where it comes in but
I don't agree with like I'm not so rigid
and thinking like happy wife happy life
and forget your husband because I just
truly believe you do need to make your
husband happy 100 what do you think
by me yeah do you think happy wife happy
life is good advice
no I think I think the husband needs to
be happy obviously both both need to be
happy but more time to husband because
he's the one that's making the money
he's going out and he's if if your man
is stressed do you think that he's going
to come home and he's gonna he's gonna
treat you right and he's gonna be he's
not he has to be happy as well
um yeah I think it's both sides I think
that happy wife happy life is a recipe
for disaster boy yeah I think it's I
think it's telling the man that you have
to try to make a woman happy and as
women I think we're never happy
I think that if you give a woman
everything you that she wants she'll
still find something she'll still find
something to not be happy about
I feel like the saying for me the way I
look at it I feel like men go through a
lot they literally have to go outside
and battle to understand and the way I
look at it I think the only thing that
can really make a man happy is his woman
that's the own that's his safe space
that's his Peace So when people say like
happy wife like when your wife is happy
that man now becomes happy like for
example you like when you're you're you
have a girl or whatever
yeah yeah sorry about that like when
she's calm and when she's happy doesn't
that bring you happiness and peace too
like compared to all the stresses of
working out or do you have like other
outlets and I'm talking like she brings
you down I need I need to add one thing
I think that's narcissism I think women
were naturally narcissistic and we take
credit for everything and I think that
he's either a happy man on a purpose or
he's not and I think women have very
little to do with it
woman play a big role in men's happiness
I think women sometimes delusional and
narcissistic
um just like by our nature
um and yeah I think we think that we
deserve more credit than we do
oh my God I feel like women definitely
make men let's just start with the fact
that where else would men get their
orgasms from women
that's how they get in yeah but that's a
moment of happiness I guess and that
Fades very quickly men typically get
happiness from doing things
it really doesn't have anything to do
with women what about peace though I'm
thinking of Peace when I say happy life
I'm thinking problem with your argument
is you're saying the woman needs to be
happy to make the man happy but the
problem with that is usually women think
that their happiness should come from
the man so the man needs to make her
happy to then let her make him happy
that doesn't make sense
so which one comes first then everyone
should be responsible for their yeah
happiness yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think it's a recipe for disaster because
you're basically telling men that you're
only gonna have a happy life if she's
happy and I think it goes back to like
like a lot of times marriage like men
view marriage as a horrible contract and
I think that's a part of it because
they're they're selling that in order
for you to be happy she has to be happy
and women are never happy I always felt
like the saying was just like uh just
take care of your wife I never really
made it meant like you have to be
responsible for that I never knew people
really took it literally but that's why
I was just like you know keep your wife
happy because I thought it was just make
sure you're taking care of your wife but
I didn't know it actually meant you're
responsible for her happiness and I
don't believe in that I don't think you
should be responsible for anyone's
happiness I don't think it's like
intentional but I think there's like a
lot of words in our society where we
like subtly give like women credit for
everything and like blame men for
everything it's very subtle I'll give
you an example of another other one not
to do with the marriage but like Knocked
Up assumes that he knocked her up yeah
so whose fault is it his
he got her pregnant like there's a lot
of really subtle things and I think
that's like just one of them
no that's that's actually true I still
feel like in a relationship everyone
should be you should practice
interdependence meaning you're able to
be independent by yourself and provide
for yourself in terms of happiness but
when you are in a relationship I think
your partner should wake up with the
need and want to actually contribute not
make you happy and be the source of your
happiness but contribute to your
happiness so in that aspect aspect I do
believe that men should contribute this
in this vice versa as well I also think
sometimes happiness is Just an Illusion
we're supposed to I think sometimes
happiness is an illusion because we're
supposed to be up and down up and down
if we're waiting until we're happy we're
never we're never
because there's always something there's
always something that we're going to
stress about yeah there's always a loss
of a family there's always a career that
I there's always something so happiness
is an illusion like you can be content
so one thing yeah I just realized oh my
gosh women we have easier lives than
ever before
we have more freedom than ever before we
have more automation than ever before
yet we're more miserable than ever
before and we're more miserable because
men tried to make us happy by giving us
everything and now we're unhappy with
all of this choice and freedom which is
spoiled yes yes it's like we're like
yeah I think we're like children
actually yeah and it's kind of like if
you give a kid everything they're like a
miserable child very true yeah yeah I
think it's the same so one thing that
you actually taught me is um you know
exactly what you just said that we're
not always going to be happy in life
learn to deal with the unhappiness learn
to deal with the stress when you're at
work do you know what she said to me she
was like you're at work and you're angry
just start smiling just enjoy the anger
yeah and there are studies that say like
that you naturally like get happier if
you're smiling all the time yeah just
just learned to deal with it that's part
of life you experience different
emotions you don't always need to be
happy sometimes you're sad and I think
sometimes if the guy is like feeding
into it every time like it's kind of
like with kids if they're having a
temper tantrum and you feed into it it's
like it gets bigger and bigger yeah yeah
yeah or if you do just shut it down I'm
a big fan of ignoring problems yeah I
think sometimes when you ignore problems
you forget and they go away I don't
think we gotta talk about every problem
or issue also just being a bit cheeky
with it I think as a man a lot of men
need to learn to just be like it's okay
baby do you know I mean just shake it
off and then and then you as a woman
would be like all right cool I'm
overreacted right instead of being like
Oh no are you okay yeah don't do that
and that's what I think that phrase like
encourages men to try to make her happy
when again I don't think men can make
women happier they're happier you're not
yeah it's a choice happiness is a choice
that you make and like life is literally
just a never-ending
story of problem solving I think Will
Smith said something one time he said
you both have to be complete before you
come together or both be happy within
your within yourself you're never going
to be complete or happy that's the whole
point no no but like
here's the thing yeah don't try to seek
happiness of your partner because then
you're gonna be stuck aren't you you're
going to be forever searching be happy
within yourself and then come together
as one could we react to um the girl's
reaction I know we started watching it
earlier but
um
yes I told you guys I told you I was
like I should tell people to wear like I
don't know just shorts yeah
oh sorry that was sorry
and next time next time I'm just gonna
come and like you know what African moms
wear
on here before I don't know he told me
to wear this
um
okay okay
um what dating advice would you guys
give to men
okay
I want Jason advice
I would say um just be honest
about just be transparent it's not by
force like and that's not just to do
with like finances and stuff but even
like emotional availability and stuff
like that like it's not that serious how
do you communicate that though on the
first day it's not on the first not on
the first day but she said dating advice
not date advice so like if you're dating
somebody like consistently my advice
would be honesty because I feel like my
pet peeve is when men are like not
honest or like not transparent I don't
really expect it straight away which is
fine but at some point just stop lying
so I think it depends on be honest be
emotionally available those are like the
two okay what about you
um maybe just be like very clear on your
intentions like where you are in your
life and what your goal is with this
woman essentially be clearing your
intentions in your intentions yeah okay
what about you I think it depends on
what you're dating for as a man what are
you dating for
uh most men want to have sex okay then
then make that clear I'm trying to so
tell her right away you want to [__] uh
now because then you're not going to get
her into bed aren't you okay so tell her
soon I think um I think it needs to be a
little bit uh not so blunt like that
okay but you know I'm not looking for
anything serious I'm just looking for
just be honest because then you're not
playing soft because when you have a
daughter it's gonna come back on you
karma is a real thing okay uh what do
you think
um yeah it depends on what what you're
going for sorry it depends what you're
going for so because don't waste my time
like I'm dating for for marriage so it's
like are you dating for the same
interest or are you dating for [__]
because if so there's lots of fishes in
the sea Hunters okay so be honest with
your intentions oh okay what I would say
study the girl ask as many questions as
possible because one thing I would say
is us women were very good at playing a
character yeah and we can play any
character that we want so when a man you
know falls in love with her beauty or
this and that and then later on in a
marriage she finds out okay she was a
[__] with a body cow 36 and now you're
divorce and now you've lost your money
is because you didn't really take the
time to study girls I feel like a lot of
men these days are going for girls just
like for vanity and just this fake
facade that they put in on and then they
and they end up finding themselves in
the [__] show like I'm not being funny
but look at Kanye and came he just fell
in love with her because of her bum and
her s tape and then now look what's
happened as soon as she made a billion
dollars she's left him and he's gone
insane he's gone insane he has no
control over what his daughter is
posting on Tick Tock why because he
didn't take the time to really study Kim
and her manipulative ways who he was
having a kid with what would you say I
want to hear from the guys
um what advice out of this was good and
what was not good see what you said
about um honest with your intentions
yeah yeah that do you know like when I
tell a girl that I don't want anything
serious and it's just going to be one of
my things to be private No One's Gonna
know like you'll have a good time blah
blah blah blah like 97 of the time
they'll just step on it
so I think that's oh they're happy to
sleep yeah happy to sleep with you
because they like
it's weird man like girls are just the
standards aren't as high anymore in
regards to what they want so and these
are not like these are some like what we
would class as high value women that
have got low body counts so you have
found that if you're more honest honest
and I feel like it goes back to what you
said about earlier about girls I want to
um travel a lot and stuff when they're
younger especially when they're bored
you know like in their board they can be
like these super good girls that present
themselves in these certain ways but
they know no one's gonna find out and
they just want a good time someone who
looks like this and so I think if if
your intentions as a guy as you sleep
with a girl yeah I think just be honest
what would you say Paul I don't think
you should get dating advice from women
that's the best advice yeah don't take
dating advice from women yeah because I
think it's a lot harder to sleep with
women
um than we know
um and so I think if you've never done
it maybe maybe the lesbian girl could
have
uh so I was just curious if if they
thought so you thought the honesty was
good anything else
not my question
because even what we said it was so
General tell her your intention to be
honest yeah a lot of questions
specific I think
um for a guy if you want to find out
about their history without asking too
many questions and then you can just ask
them simple questions like
where have you been the last year like
what a lazy been on if they've been
slapped to buy I'd be for these players
like this it's like you're
it's obvious what you've been on type
thing I always see what else what other
questions I'm curious if you asked you
know I'm normally lead we just honestly
think because I'm just looking that I'm
there for one reason and then it's cool
from there so I don't really I'm kind of
a bad person to take advice from because
people they just wanna
they um reciprocate what I want well I
think most men I mean there's men
watching most men want to know how to
get laid
you know I heavily rely on um appear
with my parents and stuff so it's just
this my life coach says to me as well
I'd be the worst person to give advice
because for me to put I just I was
standing there in the club I think it's
literally so you just you just stand
there in the club and like what when
they come up to you
yeah
that's when it's more of a younger thing
I was a younger mindset I stopped
obviously like no I'm just I'm just
curious what that's like so like women
actually approach you yeah wow that's so
rare you know that's not common for all
my friends are the gas with it they're
like they they use me as fishing but
they just tell me to stand there and
then wait until the fans come too
uh King what what are the advice did you
think was good versus bad
um
I I don't know I can't remember most of
it I've got one more like what about
what about like if you want to find out
more about her like having more like
debates and stuff to get her perspective
on on things and that can tell you a bit
about somebody as well like being more
friendly like in the beginning just
build a friendship and have debates like
what we're doing now and get her
perspective on like World issues and
current affairs and that could help a
debate that I bring up often with if I
was to meet someone for the first time
is like would you um would would you
wife would you be a wife if you slept
with over 50 people and you ask us and
they're like they're so I mean like some
of them try and um like the feminist
girls will try and argue the point of
yeah yeah like this and that but as soon
as you start talking that point I'm like
yeah I don't yeah but that's fine and
that's good though because that's a good
way of you seeing her mindset that you
don't want that I have a question for
King just out of curiosity why do you
feel like is a bad idea to get um dating
advice from women because I always
thought like if you're trying to attract
women then that's where you find out
what they're looking for so I'm kind of
curious because because women women
don't know what they want so that's the
first thing the second thing is the
second thing is most women say one thing
and do the other so if you're taking
advice for women they're just gonna tell
you what sounds good they're not going
to tell you what actually is going to
work because most of them don't even
know so the truth is at the end of the
day when you're speaking to women I even
think
the Talking part should just be together
to talk but it's more about watching
what she does it's not really about what
she says okay
she speaks louder don't worry yes I said
Pearl you nailed it happy wife happy
life is a recipe for disaster a man can
contribute to his wife's Happiness by
making her happy is an impossible task
um can you play the video now
thank you
so this was her response after the
comments
so out of the 50 000 plus comments
posted on social I only saw a handful
that even considered the possibility of
a bus owner being a more aspirational
position and recognizing that I am
actually speaking and pouring into the
Ascension of black men when I said what
I said but see no some of y'all were too
busy naming and shaming me personally
and black women in general as
undesirable gold diggers and much worse
now I suspect that some of y'all are the
same men that were bringing home C's and
D's on your report cards only to then be
cuddled by parents that said well that's
okay as long as you're doing your best
well listen I love and believe in the
Excellence of black men so no my dear
C's and D's or any other form of
mediocrity is not okay
now I will not create a soft place for
you or anybody that I love to fall
comfortably into the bigotry of low
expectations so I'm gonna say one more
time there's absolutely nothing wrong
with driving a bus my mother Gloria
drove one for years
but could it be that Black America has
been sold a narrative of average regular
and typical being good enough for us
well see that's called white supremacy
and in this case it takes the form of
conditioning black Americans to happily
accept being a permanent American
underclass
but see because I know the truth about
Black Folk in America no average is not
and will never be good enough for me and
the gag is I don't think it's good
enough for you either
what'd you guys think of a response
I'm not sure what Ray's got to do with
it yeah I didn't I didn't agree with the
whole white I think it was a bit extreme
to tying race to it actually I didn't
even watch the response before but I was
like wait what yeah I don't think we
need it and that was necessary because I
don't like I feel like we need to be
responsible for ourselves like not
always bring in the race card sometimes
but I just think I get that's that's
kind of what I was saying I just feel
like you are so entitled to your
standard and what you want and accepting
your life however you need to be aware
of the repercussions of that so if
you're going for this top one percent
just be aware that you may not ever get
it and accept that but you're still
entitled to have that as long as you're
not disrespecting other people that is
it I think it's as simple as that
what do you guys think
I think her response was lit I feel like
people are a bit too comfortable it's
like I don't know if you guys ever saw
that interview obviously Kim Kardashian
is probably the wrong person is it
because she definitely had advantages
but that interview when she was like
y'all need to work [__] hard and then
everybody got onto her as well it's like
I feel like in general people have like
a certain comfortability and I think
with her I don't think she was saying
well the whole white supremacy thing was
definitely a stretch but I feel like in
general I guess as like ethnic people
we're more comfortable with jobs like
bus drivers because in general we're
kind of like pushed down when it comes
to office jobs and stuff we might not
get that application so I thought I
could get that point but in general like
I said that this I said it from the
beginning I said her conversation she
sparked that to wake up a bus driver and
get him to work further I don't think
she was doing it to like knock them down
I personally think it's motivational if
I was a bus driver I would quit my child
but she's acting like she's so much
better than him
because she literally said she literally
said try for harder but or better but
it's like well why don't you try for
better when it's like all your do like I
just like wait wait I just think it's
mad that all she's doing is talking and
she thinks she's better than a bus
driver all you're doing is talking and
and we have so much privilege being
women where especially outside of the
especially especially when we're in
entertainment it's like we have a
privilege that men don't have and you're
gonna [__] on a guy who has a job that
makes Society run but I don't think she
said that um she thinks she's bed saw
she literally said she wants better for
them but she said to herself okay but if
she said she wouldn't date one because
she doesn't because she wants yeah like
if that's what I said it's like maybe a
cleaner or like an Uber driver might be
happy to drive a butt to to date a bus
driver but if she's a news reports on
she just happens to not want to date a
bus driver personally I don't I don't
see an issue of it I think there's okay
I think there's nothing wrong with being
aspirational but I think when you look
at things from a factual perspective the
type of person that she's is looking for
is probably a part of it's part of the
10 and 20 percent so that's why I feel
like there's like a good 70 of women
trying to grab this 20 or 10 percent of
men that will most likely not going to
be able to obtain because there's such a
small portion so I feel like that's
where she's being uh and that's why I'm
understanding everyone when they're
saying sometimes it's good to settle for
less but if she's in her ways where she
just feels like okay do you know what I
can do better and probably she's been in
rooms of people who have been doing
better then I just feel like you just
let her be because at the same time she
didn't say she wants a billionaire like
maybe she'd just prefer a train driver
like you really can't tell that's what
I'm saying is like she's entitled to her
preference she doesn't have to be you
know like a billionaire herself to not
want to date a bus driver because she's
not saying she married us
no that age hit me with it yeah yeah 12
but that doesn't mean she should be in
that song so my opinion with this I feel
like and so as a woman you should have
standards but then there is a time and
place like at that age your standards
should go a bit lower let's be honest
and then my opinion if you've got a good
Korean you feel like so hard for your
career why can't you then take care and
whether you want to do that right do it
then why do you need natural someone
yeah you want to do that you chose that
then do it why now you want someone with
a high value
like because at 22 she could have
married a provider yeah she could have
had been in that position but she chose
to go after it that's fine I'm not
knocking you for it but then you get to
that position and now you require
someone that makes more it's like well
why did you go for that yeah my question
is
why does she feel like she is above what
is it that she's doing I just want to
know like what is it that she's doing
she's clearly doing something correct
for her to have that opinion but what
part of it
above I don't know like a newscaster or
something news is important
for her to for her to feel that
um
you know but what part of what she said
made youth feel like she felt that she
was better than listening no I think
that she must be doing something great
um
I think she's just delusional listen
this is what they say listening to the
reporter's response that's why she's 39
and alone she should buy a dog it has
nothing to do with race because like my
whole point is he's in a job that makes
Society run and none of like women in
general none of us would be able to do
anything if the men didn't build Society
to a point that it runs and so now it's
like the men are building and running
society and then we come in and get
these cushy jobs and act like we're
better than the men that are doing the
hard jobs so it's not even that she's
not a high value woman it's that she is
perhaps too uh dominant in a sense not
feminine enough because why is it that
she's got a good career she looks good
why are you not married and settled down
yeah no she's what's wrong with her for
her correct and so that's why I say
she's delusional because she has this
ego yes where it's like okay if you're
40 and you're unmarried you're basically
a loser by women's standards you're a
loser and so she's be she's a loser out
here and she's sitting on an average
dude
you know what sometimes delusion pays
off so let her live in her delusion and
she will see
what's that what's the definition of
insanity doing the same thing over and
over again expecting different results
exactly that's my point yep there's no
context here with this lady that's the
hardest thing we don't even know she
might have just came out of the marriage
that he's just cheated so she's left
because she's she's confident in herself
and has the self worth to leave in that
example she's not a loser she's not I
don't I think she's actually I'm doing
the right thing women
um should stay if they get cheated on in
general you think they should stay as a
blanket statement or do you mean if he's
a provider no I think in general you
should stay because I think um women
don't care about vowels anymore and at
the end of the day you did take vows for
richer for for better for worse I think
most women at some point have accepted
attention from another man in a
relationship I think at some and so a
lot of times I think like women will
demonize men for cheating but they still
have open Instagram accounts
we're about for business though I I mean
it's still it's still a for sale sign if
your face is on so because I'm taking do
you think I should put my account on
private yeah I think you should even if
it blocks all of my business and my work
no one can see my content it doesn't
share something I mean I think it
depends what what matters to you but
yeah I think if you're with a guy that
you want to be married to I would and
what if he doesn't care
um you know it's your I'm not going to
tell you how to run your relationship
but I think in general it's just funny
because again I believe attention is to
women is sexist to men we get into a
relationship the men are expected to
stop having sex with other people but
the women are not expected to put away
Instagram and so I think a lot of times
women demonize men for cheating and make
them be this evil person but we don't
take the like the thorn out of our own
eye before throwing in the towel
when you say cheat do you mean just like
the one-off or what
um I I how do I put it like I think
there's a lot of issues that we don't
talk about in marriage and I think one
of them is that a lot of men are in
sexless marriages so the women are not
sleeping with them or they're belittling
them every day they get home and they're
just nagging nagging nagging and so then
the guy goes elsewhere because of
something the woman did and so and then
the girl will cry on social media and
say oh I was cheated on and we
immediately say ah without asking any
questions of what she had to play my
question is like if a man is to cheat
multiple times should the woman stay
ideally yeah I think you should try to
work it out it doesn't mean he'll cheat
forever but I think sometimes you have
to go through hard times so are you
trying to say like cheating is not that
steep I'm not saying cheating I'm not
saying cheating I think I always
misquote me
okay or should be inspired for it and I
think you should aim to get a guy that
doesn't cheat but what I'm saying is
like we used to believe that the family
was more important than our feelings and
now if we are hurt or damaged in a
relationship we we want to like play the
victim and act like we didn't hurt or
damage him ever yeah and there's no
understanding in relationships anymore
okay now if you are on point towards
your man and he still has this
promiscuous attitude where he wants to
go and do that then well I think you
know I I think there should be some
humility because you're probably not on
point with everything yes
you're the best that you can be and he
loves that but perhaps it's rare by the
way that a man would act that way but if
he does
I think the goal should always be to
work it out I think the goal like are
there exceptions where you should leave
sure yeah but I think as woman like and
wanting to keep families together your
goal should always be to work it out
instead of just to leave every time it
gets hard because like come on you the
girl like the girl get cheated on but
it's like you've never flirted with
another guy in a relationship ever like
come on do you say this because you're
putting children at like the epicenter
of like keeping the the family together
because I believe in marriage and I
believe in Real Marriage not the
marriage we have today so like now I
think marriage isn't marriage anymore
today I think if if you believe that you
should leave in every like bad part of a
relationship you don't you shouldn't be
married like stay out of marriage just
be in relationship to relationship but
if you believe in For Better or For
Worse for richer for poor that means
your husband might step out and you
might have to work it out and I think we
should go into like marriages knowing
that might happen and knowing our goal
is to work it out but that's why a lot
of people are not getting married
nowadays um and also on both sides
the man is also going to do things that
are wrong he also has to stay it works
both ways if I step out of line are you
staying do you know and do you hard
women to the same Regard in terms of
like if a woman cheats the magic I think
cheating is infinitely worse for women
than men I think if a woman
um cheats I would they say in the Bible
that like a woman can or a man can
divorce a woman if she cheats but they
don't say the same for a woman to a man
listen the Bible's kind of red pill with
that but I think the goal is always to
work it out I think that should be the
goal on both sides but I would you know
I'm a little biased I think if the woman
cheats he should divorce her more right
but let's even put aside the Bible as a
woman you're receiving you're receiving
you're receiving and you know yeah
you're you're getting something whereas
the man yeah you're given it's not okay
but it's very very different as a woman
yeah I think cheating's worse for women
it is is because it takes a woman is it
like that's like the final straw really
a woman cheating is the final straw
She's Not Just Gonna step out for fun
not only that but also in the Bible and
in the Quran it says that like women are
just more precious physically yeah you
know men were created by dust so that
means not to say you guys are dirty yeah
whilst women we actually come from the
man's room so therefore we are way more
precious so when we cheat it does hurt
and I also want to add to the point that
keeping the family together just creates
a healthy Society because we all know
that when kids um come from a broken
home they become more damaged and they
become more confused and they start to
do things so I agree on the point that
you should make it work but I'm still
looking but that is why it's so
important for the husband as well
because the woman is just trying it's
not okay for the kids I've seen that
happen where the woman is giving giving
giving and the man is just doing what he
wants no it works both ways I think I
think yeah but without like talking with
exceptions to stuff because there's
always odd this could be he could be
abusive he could be this uh without
talking let's say a healthy relationship
and that occurred I do believe we should
work it out and Yeah and I don't and and
I don't condone I don't I it shouldn't
happen in the first place but
realistically would he be looking
somewhere else if we didn't if if he
didn't receive it at home if he did if
he didn't have the home
um environment would he go look
somewhere else and I'm talking if we
could we're not going to talk about
exceptions because we there is bad man
as well with that but except the good
relationship yeah I think I think you
know I can actually justify a man
cheating if it's not getting it from his
wife I can completely or if she's
bringing [__] I can I can get that I
have a question for the men I feel like
a lot of men say that you can love a
woman and still like you know have sex
with another woman like I actually want
you guys to break it down to be like how
does that work where you can you know
love one woman but do something to her
at the same time but still say you love
her like would you be able to answer
that question how does that work yes
because men like to bust nuts
I can see how that could work though
so that's it it's just busting the night
what if butt in the nut is gonna break
away from the other my love for you
biology
think about it biologically
if a woman gets pregnant she's out for
almost nine months and a man still has
to burst nuts so biologically one woman
really can't satisfy a man he can do
that with her if if a man cheats on his
pregnant wife that's disgusting oh
that's mad I'm not talking about the
morality I'm talking about the facts
yeah yeah but that's what you're based
on that time period yeah it seems like
it's like you demonize him so quick oh
that's disgusting yeah like but that's
what I'm saying we lack understanding
for man
you do based on that response like
because your immediate response is oh
that's disgusting instead of and so
right I know it's fine but I'm saying
like I'm saying as a society we lack
understanding for men instead of like
understanding where they're coming from
you know if she's not sleeping you with
you and she's pregnant it's hard for a
guy so that's hard so what I've base it
on is um the woman is still wanting to
sleep with her man but he views her a
lot of men they get turnt off during the
woman's pregnancy right the she doesn't
look the same so therefore they look
elsewhere that is a type of uh in my
eyes that is disgusting and that's the
type of man that you you want to avoid
that's crazy that's what I'm talking
about I don't mean like oh I see I don't
mean a good man who's who's you know the
woman's turning him down he's looking
elsewhere that's different if you're if
your woman's willing to give it to you
and you're just looking at thinking oh
she looks ugly yeah yeah is that a thing
like man you sleep with her pregnant
yeah have you not heard of that the
percentages
now I think
women kind of like have these horror
stories that were just like propagate
because women are more susceptible to
like propaganda to be honest so I think
there's like a bunch of like programming
where they just give us these crazy
stories that don't realize in the baby's
head and stuff no no I mean but the
story that I just gave is that we yeah
not just you but like one of them yeah I
like I like the you know you guys how
many times have people mentioned abuse
in the show yeah like why is that even
mentioned all the time like like this is
left and right men are abusing women
it's just not women are abusing men as
well yeah right but I'm saying like
that's always the woman's immediate
response is like what's the worst that
can happen yeah it's like a gut like
whenever we talk about things that women
are doing wrong it's always like gut
reaction what's the worst that can
happen I've just noticed since I've been
doing this for so long
um okay Pearl for sense for better for
worse point blank than if the white wife
cheats repeatedly should the husband
stay and work it out yes
I gotta be honest cheating's different
um maybe I'm a little bit I know they're
gonna clip me if I say that but but no
you know um I think the idea should
always be to work it out if you can but
uh I do think cheat is different for men
and for women so
um but bus drivers in New York City are
top five percent earners my neighbor
raised three kids and retired his wife
as a bus driver this is nuts
um
okay
um I think I'm gonna close out the show
because we're almost hitting three hours
now
um thank you guys for coming
um we're gonna do final thoughts so you
can give any final thoughts you got on
bus drivers or life or whatever I'm
starting here and then go around
um so my final thoughts is that whatever
that woman's name was the presenter
um like I said I personally think she's
lit um I think she's very like proud of
where she's at in life and she doesn't
want a bus driver she doesn't want a bus
driver that's just her life
um in terms of the marriage and stuff
they're cheating and stuff like nobody
should chew boy or girl man or woman I
feel like if you've made vowels in front
of your family in front of God like
think about the money spent on a dress
on the wing on the rings on everything
is like why would you want to cheat
let's just not do that
um and then other than that
um yeah I think in terms of dating it's
all going average and above average I
feel like as long as you're bettering
yourself on your ambitious and you're
trying to not be average then I feel
like you you're valid in like trying to
date somebody who like coordinates that
they might be average going above
average or like above average but yeah
that's just my final points
um so in regards to the lady the news
anchor I would say yeah I think she's
totally entitled to have her standard
and to stick to it as well not be swayed
as well by what anyone has to say about
what she wants to accept in her life or
from a man
um as long as it's coming from a place
where she knows she deserves it or she
might be delusional but she has to also
accept that with that comes the
repercussions of like limited uh
prospects like she may not get that
question yeah she's delusional do you
think that if she should change her
standards yes okay yeah I do yeah I'm
basing it on the fact that she is title
to this standard oh yeah if she's not
getting the men she wants then isn't she
delusional
um
she'll be married
There's Hope
no there's hope there's hope that's
right how is their hope no this is 12 of
Hope okay so because it's not zero
There's Hope absolutely okay God loves
the Trier
um yeah
Strivers listen I I don't want to see if
she met a good bus driver good character
good man that would take care of her and
if he was obviously not the 15 pound an
hour but if he was one of the top three
earners whatever she should go for it
okay 100 go ahead
um yeah gone
um I think a lot of good points have
been made here today I think also if you
are a woman that does aspire to be
married
um it's important to know what your man
wants and adjust to that I've had to do
it myself I was I was very
um in a sense yeah dominant and kind of
knew what I wanted and I've had to
change myself Etc so I think also a lot
of points that have been made here today
have also opened my eyes in a sense and
I'm always open to learning so yeah um
thank you for having me thanks for
coming go ahead
um I think I'm glad to the bus driver I
think we need to view him as like more
than like his job title I agree he's
still a human and he can bring a lot
more to the table than just being a bus
driver he might he might have had a mad
life before crazy stories and education
they can teach you a lot and everything
like that so I think maybe we shouldn't
just judge him as a bus driver
immigration marriage and things like
that I believe that
um I believe that marriage isn't a
necessity in this day and age because if
I'm asking my partner to give up her
whole career in life to be my wife and
to raise my kids and to nurture me and
love me that she's given up a whole
um career potentially so yeah she needs
some security she needs like half of my
[__] so I believe that some a good thing
and yeah things have on me thanks for
coming go ahead
um regarding the bus driver I'm not
gonna lie do you think the woman is
delusional I'm sorry it just have gotten
the age like we have to we have to be
realistic oh 38. she's 39. you caught
alone
I don't think you can but it's going to
be very difficult so 20 years on the
market that's a long time it's like you
didn't sell a product for 20 years you
might lower the price a little bit a
little bit I mean at least
[Laughter]
but if you want marriage but why are you
marrying for for a tribe for marriage so
if you if you're looking for that then I
don't think at your age you should be
that picky
um respectfully uh
um and also thank you for having me it
was great I've learned a lot I've had
lots of knowledge and thank you again
thanks for coming glad
um I think that God is the greatest and
his word does not lie and it says in the
Bible that you should a woman should
look for someone that's going to protect
them provide for her
um so therefore she is almost allowed to
look up or look for someone that's going
to do that for her
um it's okay to there's some
circumstances where a girl has dated a
guide that's doing less than him and
it's worked out that's possible and I
encourage women especially who are older
to do that but I feel like don't drop
your standards too low and I feel like
the bus driver to TV presenter that's
way too low for her maybe a lawyer maybe
a teacher your business owner stay on
the Bible it says provide but what's it
going to do you didn't say provide a
crazy lifestyle yeah but it's like I
just feel like that but I feel like the
bus driver is working if you could feed
and clothe himself and like has an
apartment for himself like she could
just go into his apartment
I feel like with her like let's be
realistic she's accustomed to her
lifestyle and she's comfortable in that
lifestyle so she's going to want someone
to kindness no I understand I just don't
understand like that's not biblical
you must date a guy like if you choose
like it's not biblical to wait till
you're 40 to get married sleep with a
bunch of dudes uh make a bunch of money
and then ask for a guy that makes more
of them yeah and I agree with that and
that's her mistake and that's where
she's 39 and single right but I feel
like at the end of the day God is the
greatest and I feel like met women we
should follow what the prince of what
the Bible says about what you should
look for in a man and it's the same
thing with women as well and I'm telling
and I'm agreeing with the fact that she
didn't follow the biblical sense that's
why that's why she's in that position
and she's finding herself in a situation
where she's arguing online over a bus
driver whatever but I just think
everyone should follow the Bible if we
did she wouldn't be in that position and
no one would be arguing about no I just
I'm confused like I'm gonna provide
stuff because he doesn't say provide how
much
like he's working yeah sounds like he's
unemployed he's unemployed I'm not
saying it's impossible for him to
provide obviously if he's a bus driver
he can provide something but what I'm
saying is that she's accustomed to her
lifestyle so for example
um the queen oh rest in peace she's
accustomed to a certain lifestyle but
just because the bus driver can provide
a penny for her that doesn't mean now
like she can you know you know she's
accustomed to her life it's like living
and maintaining like and you want to
maintain it so yeah she wants to be
saying that lifestyle yeah that's just
that's just me being completely
realistic with the fact that there's
some woman they just want a certain
lifestyle that's it and they want to
remain in that so with that being said
they just want to stick with that the
guy adding 50p more to that is not
really that's not really like the
provision that she's looking for so I
know in the Bible it doesn't say that
but what I'm trying to say is that like
there's people who are comfortable in
their lifestyle and if they want to
remain in that then we should just let
them and if that ends up being her fault
and she's six D with like seven Cuts
then that is on her okay thank you and
thank you for having me thank you for
coming
um a couple announcements guys before we
end the show um you already know two
clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily also uh four membership
tiers first here you get to be a part of
the live chat second tier Discord Vlogs
third tier you connect with me on social
media and for the Tierra 101 call follow
my Instagram to submit topics for the
show just probably things one
um or if you have something you want me
to react to
subscribe to wife school um thank you
for the super chats today like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
she's back again with another podcast
good evening and hi and welcome to
Auntie Jenny's Village Nancy Jenny's
podcast it's your boy The Fresh Prince
of someone
but I'm in coffee free for four months
okay I gotta say that how could everyone
have someone out there for them when
there's more women than men now I'm not
saying you have to be submissive to
every old waste man walking around I'm
just saying that it would be femininity
would be in your nature breaking it is
to find somebody you're compatible with
that you'd like not just of your same
generation and that likes the same
things that you do going out having fun
then get out okay okay then then get out
then get out faster then get out I'm not
here to get canceled today most men want
a woman that has some degree of
femininity where they feel like they're
taking care of taking care of I'm
ladylike I'm submissive and you'll be
surprised because I will say what I want
to say now and I'll say well I want to
say with my mind but my demeanor doesn't
change and I'm gonna look down on him
because at the end of the day whoever
you're with is a reflection of you what
has happened to society that has made
the normal man a waste man I would feel
so bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag now he's
[Music]
[Applause]